l'offre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
door
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
les français veulent savoir savoir ce
qui attend la sécurité sociale ce bien
qui leur appartient et qui creusent
aujourd'hui un déficit abyssal du jamais
vu après avoir évoqué au sénat un
déficit de 41 milliards d'euros on en
arrive à 92 milliards d'euros
en ajoutant les propositions pour
l'hôpital ainsi que les nombreuses
promesses qui ont qui sont passées et à
venir et sans parler de la loi autonomie
et dépendance évaluée entre 7 et 10
milliards d'euros par monsieur libos et
sans parler évidemment de la
revalorisation attendue salariale des et
professionnels de santé et qui rend la
revalorisation très méritée on assiste
au déficit le plus monstrueux des
dernières années trois fois plus que
celui de 2009 2010 après la crise
économique
il est vrai qu'après avoir subi l'effet
des gilets jaunes en 2019
la crise sanitaire fait plonger
l'assurance maladie et la qos vous fait
voler en éclats la date de 2024 de fin
de la cad s est là de la loi organique
de 2010 de 2010 oui vous fait voler en
éclats la dette qui va être supérieur à
130 milliards d'euros pour l'assurance
maladie et existe bien entendu le retour
à l'équilibré
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est simple la représentation nationale
comme les français veulent connaître vos
intentions veulent connaître quelles
seront les solutions budgétaires dans le
domaine de la sécurité sociale je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
christine dubon secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des solidarités et de la
santé merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous siéger dans
cette assemblée depuis quelques temps et
vous en connaissez parfaitement les
rouages et vous savez bien que la
situation actuelle n'est pas ne se doit
aussi en lien avec ce qui s'est passé
dans le passé au delà de la crise que
nous vivons nous avons fait des efforts
importants pour ramener le déficit de la
dette de la sécu sociale il y a encore
de cela quelques mois nous traversons
actuellement une crise et c'est par
rapport à cette crise que nous devons
faire évoluer notre système de santé
c'est bien dans ce cadre là que nous
devons répondre aux besoins des
soignants besoins des usagers aux
besoins des patients pour adapter notre
système de santé à la tente qui est
forte et qui est important shit
important de rappeler que nous avons
inversé la tendance dans le sens où nous
avons réinvesti massivement dans
l'hôpital parce que c'est en
réinvestissement en ré investissant
massivement dans l'hôpital que nous
pourrons apporter une réponse dans
l'hôpital mais également ce lien avec la
médecine de ville qui est nécessaire
répondre aux besoins des territoires à
partir des territoires et avec
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales c'est tout ce qui a porté
la réforme de la santé 2022 nous devons
aller plus loin et c'est parce que nous
devons aller plus loin que nous devons
aussi prendre en compte la question de
la dépendance que nous faisons ce choix
de réinvestissement dans notre système
de santé pour répondre à l'avenir et
répondre à santé future de nos citoyens
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
député vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame vous ne
répondez pas à ma question celle de la
compensation de la tête sociales
supérieures à 130 milliards d'euros
comment allez vous faire donnez-nous les
solutions au niveau de la cades est ce
au niveau de la loi organique de 2010
sont l éliminer merci
monsieur de député madame la ministre le
député ce sujet sera entièrement traités
et les travailler puisqu'il s'agit d'une
loi organique avec les parlementaires
vous y serez entièrement associés merci
madame la ministre la parole est à
madame mode petit pour une question de
monsieur max mathiasin on écoute mal un
petit s'il vous plaît vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président je me
fais porte-parole de mon collègue max
mathiasin député de guadeloupe qui
s'adresse à madame la ministre d outre
mer madame la ministre la crise
sanitaire et les surcoûts exorbitants du
fret aérien ont contribué
considérablement accru les difficultés
liées à la cherté de la vie les prix
flambent les tpe qui représente la très
grosse majorité de notre tissu
économique luttent pour leur survie
certes le gouvernement a mis en place
des aides très utile pour les
entreprises comme le fonds de solidarité
mais à peine un tiers de nos tpe a pu en
bénéficier
à cause en particulier de la fracture
numérique
le tourisme est à l'arrêt et l'économie
ne reprendra pas dans les prochains mois
c'est pourquoi les tpe ultramarines
demande une exonération totale des
cotisations fiscales et sociales pour
l'année 2020
cette mesure concerne tous les artisans
et pas seulement ceux du secteur du
tourisme de la restauration
je pense par exemple aux taxiteurs et à
tous ces métiers de proximité
indispensable à la population
l'urgence concerne aussi bien sûr les
familles les plus fragiles
la prestation d'accueil en restauration
scolaire versée directement au
bénéficiaire de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire doit pouvoir bénéficier
également aux familles qui ont des
enfants de moins de 6 ans et aussi les
enfants dans l'enseignement supérieur et
surtout une solution doit être trouvée
pour permettre l'accès de toute la
famille aux produits de première
nécessité cela pourrait passer par une
réglementation des prix de ses produits
ou une baisse significative du bouclier
qualité prix sur les produits de grande
consommation
vous le savez madame la ministre la
situation peut vite devenir critique
dans ces territoires
le taux de chômage est déjà actuellement
en guadeloupe par exemple de près de 50%
chez les jeunes
les artisans les familles sont dans des
situations très préoccupante voire
dramatique
il s'agit véritablement d'éviter une
catastrophe sociale
alors madame la ministre allez vous
entendre ces demandes et mettre en
oeuvre les mesures indispensables et
urgentes pour sauver les artisans et
lutter contre la cherté de la vie en
guadeloupe comme dans l'ensemble des
territoires en outre-mer et ça fait
longtemps qu'on le demande merci chers
collègues la parole thomas dames annick
girardin ministre d outre mer monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
les
les députés madame la députée petit au
nom du député max matter hasard vous me
demandez de mettre en place des mesures
indispensables et urgentes
mais vous le savez ces mesures
nous faisons que ça de les mettre en
place depuis le début de cette crise et
notamment effectivement en direction des
territoires ultramarins que ce soit pour
les entreprises que ce soit pour nos
concitoyens et nous sommes bien sûr aux
côtés des collectivités pour les
entreprises dans les territoires
ultramarins des cellules de crise ont
été mises en place et j'ai demandé au
préfet de regarder les demandes
d'entreprises au cas par cas en tenant
compte des spécificités de chaque
territoire pour la guadeloupe c'est 383
millions d'euros qui ont été injectés
pour que l'état assume la rémunération
de soixante deux mille emplois dans le
cadre de l'activité partielle ses 275
millions de prêts de trésorerie accordé
à ce jour et puis en traitement et à 326
millions d'euros également pour de
nouvelles entreprises ces vingt-deux
mille entreprises bénéficiaires du fonds
de solidarité vous l'avez signalé pour
lesquels là aussi j'avais demandé au
préfet et ça a été fait de rester souple
sur les mesures se sont également trois
mille sept cents artisans indépendants
qui ont été aidés par le conseil de la
protection sociale des travailleurs
indépendants vous le savez nous l'avons
dit promu nice l'a rappelé nous voulons
éviter les drames des faillites et du
chômage
bien sûr les familles les familles les
plus modestes notamment en aussi été au
coeur de nos préoccupations
inversement et vous l'avez annoncé
directe de la part cela prestations
d'accueil de restauration scolaire a été
versée bien sûr dans les territoires
ultramarins et notamment en guadeloupe
ces 12 millions d'euros qui ont été
ré orienter vers le famille les familles
à celle à ça s'ajoute une aide d'urgence
qui a été mise également en place pour
qui a bénéficié au rsa et aux
bénéficiaires du rsa bien sûr et de la
ssc 11,7 millions d'euros en guadeloupe
et sur les prix et pour finir je
voudrais dire qu'il ya un rapport qui
est sortie en toute transparence je le
publie de la concurrence la parole est à
monsieur hervé berville merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé hier le premier
ministre et vous même avez ouvert avec
les nombreux acteurs de la santé et du
grand âge la grande concertation sur la
refondation de notre système de santé
ce ségur de la santé répond directement
à l'aggravement pris par le président de
la république il ya tout juste un mois
de déployer un plan massif
d'investissement dans notre système de
santé et de revalorisation de l'ensemble
des carrières
personne ne pourra nier que les plans
voter ici au cours des trois dernières
années ont permis d'enrayer en partie la
baisse continue des budgets de la santé
depuis 20 ans et d'engager un processus
de restructuration de notre système de
choix en chantant d'une logique purement
comptable avec notamment la sortie
progressive de la tarification à
l'activité
mais la vérité nous oblige à reconnaître
que nous n'avons pas su répondre aux
nombreuses attentes fortes légitime et
précises notamment en termes de
reconnaissance et de valorisation des
personnels soignants
je pense en particulier aux
aides-soignants aux infirmiers ou encore
aux aides médico psychologiques pour ne
citer qu'eux nous devons être au rendez
vous car au delà de leurs connaissances
liées à la mobilisation sans précédent
des soignants dans cette crise c'est le
coeur même de notre combat pour une
société plus juste et centré d'abord sur
l'humain une société où chacun vit
dignement de son travail et surtout le
travail paie tout simplement mieux paix
à la hauteur de son apport dans la
société à la mesure de son rôle dans
notre vie collective penser demain
rebâtir notre système de soins c'est
aussi nous donner les moyens de
construire l'avenir de l'hôpital
et si ce sont deux points monsieur me
disent que je souhaite insister dans le
plan d'investissement pour l'hôpital
quelle place pour les investissements du
quotidien l'achat d'équipements et 2 de
ce qu'on le qualifie de petites
fournitures ses besoins
d'investissements que le premier
disqualifiée hier à juste titre de peu
spectaculaire
ce sont cependant nécessaires pour les
soignants les non soignants et cruciaux
pour la qualité des soins en temps de
crise mais aussi en tant plus normal
mais vous le savez la situation des
hôpitaux que ce soit dans la
circonscription auger hc dinan saint
malo ou au chu de grenoble ne sont pas
les mêmes alors pouvez nous dire quelles
seront la méthode déployés pour garantir
que dans chaque hôpital dans chaque
établissement
chacun et les moyens si eelv
investissement de monsieur merci la
parole comme dames christelle du boss
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député merci de
rappeler que c'est bien cette majorité
qui a inversé la tendance et redonner du
souffle à l'hôpital public
vous maintenez vous m'interrogez sur
l'investissement qui est justement un
des piliers que nous avons identifiées
au sein de ségur de la santé il nous
faut engager une nouvelle politique une
nouvelle politique d'investissement et
de financement au service des soins et
investir dans la santé c'est refuser de
faire peser sur la qualité des soins et
les conditions de travail la vétusté du
matériel et les locaux nous savons que
ces retards sont cumuls sont accumulées
dans les investissements significative
au quotidien dans les soignant et les
patients
olivier ferrand qui est absent parce
qu'ils lancent aujourd'hui les travaux
de fond sur un négociations qui débutent
dès cet après-midi s'est engagée à
construire une nouvelle doctrine en
interrogeant notre système de santé et
les défis immenses auxquels il fait face
aujourd'hui investir dans la santé c'est
se donner un nouvel horizon pour
répondre davantage à des besoins de
santé plutôt qu'à des logiques
comptables pour un investissement
soucieux d s'ancrer dans des territoires
et des projets territoriaux dans un
investissement durable
enfin est capable de nous protéger sur
le terre sur le long terme face aux
nouveaux risques sur la méthode le
calendrier nous l'avons rappelé je me
permets de le redire le comité de segura
nationale a été installé ce matin avec
des premiers échanges sur les quatre
piliers
cet après midi le groupe figure
nationale sur les carrés carrière et
rémunération est installé avec le
lancement des premières négociations
les conclusions seront rendues mi
juillet souvent mercer
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur adrien cnas
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
personne n'était prêt nous dit le chef
de l'état peut-être mais on ne peut pas
s'en contenter
pourquoi nous n'étions nous pas comment
l'être la prochaine fois l'hôpital a été
gérée comme une entreprise par la voix
de sa commission l'union européenne à
exiger des dizaines de fois que les
états membres fassent des économies dans
le secteur de la santé et les
gouvernements successifs on appliquait
avec zèle et enthousiasme ses
recommandations gérant l'hôpital comme
on tient des comptes
ainsi en 15 ans nous avons perdu 69
mille lits entre votre accession au
pouvoir et la fin de l'année dernière
quatre mille cinq cents nouvelles
fermetures ou êtes chez vous pendant ces
longs mois précédant la crise du coc
vite 19 pendant lesquelles le personnel
hospitaliers étaient en grève et en
manifestations allant jusqu à subir les
charges de gaz lacrymogène pour dire
combien la situation était critique et
exiger des moyens humains et matériels
vous le savez monsieur le premier
ministre si le point de rupture n'a pas
été atteint ce n'est que grâce à leur
dévouement absolu
nous ne voulons plus jamais voir nos
soignants en sacs poubelles nous ne
voulons plus en voir mourir faute
d'avoir pu disposer du matériel de
protection qu'ils étaient en droit
d'attendre
à l'heure de votre ségur de la santé
pourquoi remettre sur la table la
question des 35 heures et du temps de
travail le personnel n'a t-il pas
suffisamment fait preuve de dévouement
et de capacité d'adaptation à vos yeux
s'il doit y avoir un énième plan santé
l'heure est venue de donner suite à
leurs revendications
revaloriser fortement les bas salaires
embaucher et former en quantité
suffisante pour soulager les effectifs
arrêter la politique de fermetures de
lits et leur réduction programmée
démocratiser la santé en impliquant
professionnels et usagers augmenter
autant qu'il le faudra le prochain
budget de la santé pour répondre enfin
aux besoins en ville et à l'hôpital
par pitié en résumé monsieur le premier
ministre reconfirmer le maquereau nisme
est fait
enfin ce qui doit être fait merci cher
qu'avec l'apport d'intervet dames
christelle du boss secrétaire d'état du
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur
dans mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je crois que les
soignants et notre système de santé
mérite bien mieux que des polémiques la
réforme de la santé conduite depuis 2010
est une bonne réforme
les mesures prises vont dans le bon sens
mais maintenant l'ampleur de la crise
hospitalière nous oblige à accélérer à
être à la hauteur des attentes des
soignants donc oui nos objets de notre
objectif est clair nous allons augmenter
les rémunérations élaborer un plan
d'investissements ambitieux et
enclencher une transformation profonde
de tous ceux qui ne tirent pas l'hôpital
vers le haut la question de rémunération
est au coeur de notre réflexion nous
avons entendu des attentes mais la
question des rémunérations c'est aussi
celle de la montée en compétences et des
missions des médecins exercent
aujourd'hui des missions de formation de
recherche qui doivent être reconnus il
doit pouvoir faire évoluer leurs
compétences l'ensemble des
professionnels doit pouvoir faire
évoluer leurs compétences leur mission
est de ceux qui le souhaitent et le
reconnaître à leur juste valeur il faut
pouvoir offert des métiers aux soins et
en adaptant aux nouveaux besoins de
prise en charge des patients je les dis
un groupe ségur nationale se réunit et
lancé aujourd'hui spécifiquement sur
cette question et sur la question des 35
heures la question n'est pas tant de
dérégler le temps de temps de travail
mais il s'agit aussi d'obliger de pardon
il ne s'agit pas d'obliger les gens à
travailler davantage mais de créer un
cadre de créer un cadre plus s'ouvre
pour permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent
de le faire ou d'organiser le temps de
travail différemment il faut aussi
valoriser le travail des équipes et ce
qu'a lancé hier le premier ministre le
ministre de la santé
ce travail qui a été lancé ce sont 3 300
acteurs du monde de la santé qui était
présent hier des élus des représentants
des usagers les ordres professionnels
des représentants du secteur sanitaire
et médico-social et syndicats
hospitaliers les représentants des
étudiants des représentants les
transports sanitaires et les conseils
nationaux professionnels c'est tous
ensemble que nous trouverons la solution
merci mme la ministre
la parole est à monsieur patrick head
zèle merci beaucoup monsieur le
président avant de débuter ma question
qui s'adressera à monsieur le premier
ministre et qui concerne les élections
municipales je voudrais tout d'abord en
profité pour féliciter les maires et les
adjoints au maire qui ont déjà été élu
et qui vont l'être dans les prochaines
heures dans plus de trente mille
communes de france
bonne chance à eux dans l'exercice de ce
beau mandat de maire
monsieur le premier ministre le 4
septembre dernier
vous avez déclaré très solennellement la
chose suivante chaque ministre pourra
être candidat aux municipales
mais je précise immédiatement que la
règle selon laquelle on ne peut pas
cumuler sa fonction de ministre avec la
tête d'un exécutif local reste bien
entendu valables
manifestement vous n'appliquez pas la
règle que vous avez pourtant vous même
et non c'est lorsqu'il s'agit du
ministre du budget d'ailleurs absent
aujourd'hui on se demande pourquoi
monsieur d'arman alors monsieur le
premier ministre
question est simple où est chez vous le
respect de la parole donnée
où sont passées vos engagements vous qui
par ailleurs fait toujours la leçon aux
autres auriez vous comme pour les
masquer là aussi une nouvelle fois menti
aux français monsieur le premier
ministre nous attendons votre réponse
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur monsieur le député ed zèle
merci pour votre excellente question qui
nous permet de faire en réponse 3
remarque d'abord je voudrais m'associer
à vos propos de félicitations à
l'endroit de tous ceux qui élus au
premier tour ont été installés maire
adjoint aux maires conseillers
municipaux ils sont sur le point pour
certains d'entre eux ils viennent de
commencer à exercer leurs fonctions
c'est un moment exaltant ils le font
dans une période extrêmement délicate
bien sûr et je veux leur souhaiter à
tous quels que soient leurs préférences
politiques bien entendu un salut
républicain et mes voeux d'encouragement
et de succès la deuxième remarque que je
veux faire c'est une remarque en forme
de remerciement car votre question me
permet de me réjouir publiquement de
l'élection du ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics à la mairie de
tourcoing après un très beau score au
premier tour des élections municipales
et je crois je crois que monsieur le
député vous êtes pour lui comme pour les
autres aussi sensible à ce succès
électoral tout à fait exceptionnelle et
je m'associe à votre à votre joie et il
n'est pas impossible que la mienne soit
réelle et que la vôtre le soit un peu
moins mais c'est comme ça
troisième remarque puisque vous avez été
précis permettez-moi de l'être également
vous avez cité des propos que j'ai tenus
le 4 septembre 2019 et vous les avez
cités très correctement bien entendu
très complètement enfin vous les avez
cités très complètement mais vous avez
oublié les deux phrases qui était après
la déclaration vous avez évoqué ce qui
est regrettable qu'elle re étape parce
que
c'était peut-être c'était peut-être un
moment d'inattention de votre part et
aux faux autant l'être puisque vous me
demander d'être précis alors je
n'indique donc qu'après la phrase que
vous avez cités j'ai indiqué ce qui veut
dire qu'il appartiendra à ceux qui sont
candidats
le moment venu monsieur le député le
moment venu et s'ils sont élus de
déterminer si oui ou non ils veulent
rester membre du gouvernement aussi
choisir ou non d'exercer des fonctions à
la tête de l'exécutif auquel il aurait
été élu je n'ajoute ni ne retranche rien
de ce que j'ai dit le 4 septembre 2019
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur d'sel merci
beaucoup monsieur le président le
premier ministre
le moment est venu par ailleurs il y
avait une promesse présidentielle
celle-ci indiquait clairement que dans
le nouveau monde il n'y aurait pas de
cumul entre une fonction de maire et
celle de ministre
et puis ensuite nous sommes dans une
dans un moment grave vous l'avez à
plusieurs reprises rappelé ici
évidemment la tribune monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez raison avec
la pandémie est bien le ministre du
budget doit être un ministre qui
exercent à plein temps
sa fonction de ministre ça n'est pas le
cas il ya un véritable problème
gouvernementale et c'est vous qui devez
l'assumé merci monsieur le député la
parole est à monsieur paul andré
colobane merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues la
crise sanitaire sans précédent que nous
traversons a brutalement mise en lumière
les forces notre système de santé mais
aussi et surtout ses faiblesses à tel
point que nous avons craint qu'il ne
finisse par céder sur sur le poids des
conséquences d'une politique de
réduction des moyens alloués à la santé
qui pèse sur lui depuis plusieurs
décennies en tant que médecin j'ai pu
constater les failles suite à
l'apparition en corse du cluster
d'ajaccio manque de gl de masques
découvrions de lits de réanimation de
personnel
les capacités de réaction et
d'innovation dans nos territoires ont
cependant permis de répondre
efficacement à l'échelle locale afin
d'endiguer un virus qui lui n'était pas
un jacobin le pire a certes été évité
grâce au personnel soignant qui malgré
une extrême tension psychologique et
physique ont lutté avec courage et
ténacité en première ligne nous les en
remercions à nouveau ici mais ce ne sont
pas des remerciements qui nous demandent
ce sont des changements le ségur de la
sentiers de la santé pardon n'est pas le
premier plan que vous annoncez dans cet
hémicycle pour pour sauver un secteur
qui demeure en profonde souffrance et
qui doit être ce ségur la santé doit
être à la hauteur de l'événement vu les
circonstances exceptionnelles vous devez
changer de logiciel et vous affranchir
de votre méthode habituelle faux
semblant de concertation multiples et
fed annonce et peu de concrétisation sur
la forme les professionnels de santé ne
se contenteront pas de nouveau effet
d'annonce auquel ils ne croient plus au
contraire y réclame des mesures fortes
concrète une revalorisation du salaire
des soignants la fin de la logique
désastreuse de fermeture des lits et des
hôpitaux de proximité
derrière ce manque de moyens se cache
également un dysfonctionnement majeur
dans l'organisation des soins car la
crise
ducobu 19 est aussi celle de la
technostructure sanitaires et de son
hôtel au centrisme le ségur de la santé
doit permettre de repenser le mode de
gouvernance avec une nouvelle
organisation du système de santé l
écoute de territoire saurais vous
répondre à cette attente madame ministre
saura se montrer à la hauteur de ce défi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
mme anne krystel du buzz secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le député à mesdames et messieurs député
monsieur le député vous avez raison les
ségur de la santé doit répondre aux
attentes des soignants cette crise a
révélé
bien des difficultés mais elle a aussi
révélé l'engagement de ceux dont
l'ambition est de prendre soin et de
guérir l'hôpital comme à la ville nous
devons être à la hauteur de
l'opportunité qui est face à nous quatre
piliers dans ce secteur de la santé le
premier chantier c'est celui de la
transformation des métiers de la
revalorisation je viens d'en parler
deuxième chantier c'est celui d'une
nouvelle politique d'investissement et
de financement au service des soins
le troisième chantier consiste à
simplifier radicalement les
organisations et le quotidien des
équipes en leur confiant plus de levier
et d'action et de décision
le quatrième chantier le dernier
chantier dont qui fait écho à votre
question vise à fédérer les acteurs de
la santé dans les territoires au service
des usagers
il y aura des consultations elles se
sont lancées hier après midi jeux les
rappeler avec plus de 300 acteurs
d'horizons différents c'est bien de tous
ensemble que nous trouverons ensemble la
solution à partir des territoires à
partir de ce qui a été fait dans la
gestion de cette crise parce que c'est
bien à partir de ces expériences qui ont
fonctionné que nous devons développer
les méthodes et les moyens
il y aura donc des consultations jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juin avec l'ensemble
des acteurs des concertations au niveau
national à travers le du commis à
travers le comité national ségur piloté
par nicole notât pardon et un groupe
ségur nationale qui spécifique autour
des carrières et de la rémunération qui
débute dès aujourd'hui et qui se réunira
une fois par semaine jusqu'à la fin de
ségur santé nous souhaitons également
accueillir et recueillir les retours
d'expérience comme je viens de vous le
dire à partir des territoires et 7
retours d'expériences commencera dès
vendredi et nous souhaitons également
que les parlementaires qui souhaitent
s'investir puisse le faire leurs portes
est notre porte est ouverte je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur joachim sonne forget merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre vous qui aimez tant
l'europe
dites moi où est passé le couple franco
allemand car je vous entend bien
demander la solidarité avec l'allemagne
mais pourquoi se donner autant de mal
pour ne pas lui ressembler dans
l'exercice de vos fonctions
pourquoi obliger vous autant de
commerces et restaurants à rester fermés
alors que l'allemagne et la suisse ont
des conflits nés depuis longtemps at on
constaté l'apa une reprise du coc u19
y aurait-il un microclimat en france une
frontière fictifs comme pour le nuage de
tchernobyl où étaient encore le couple
franco-allemand que nous courions après
des masques y arriverons
la guerre quand l'allemagne s'équiper à
tour de bras et certifiés avec ces
organismes de certification l'allemagne
également tester tester testait comme
disait le ms quand vous remettez en
question la véracité de ces actions et
vous abritant quand ça qu'on cela vous
arrange et derrière l'om est ce pour une
prétendue inutilité du port du masque
qui semble bien loin aujourd'hui
l'allemagne n'avait pas non plus subi
une telle surmortalité chez ces
personnes âgées ni connu les problèmes
informatiques à peine avouables qui
empêché santé publique france de faire
remonter les incidences de des scènes
morbidité en ehpad
toutes les mesures que vous pourriez
annoncé jeudi seront peut-être bien venu
mais de toute façon bien tardive
avez vous songé aux souffrances que tous
ces retards et hésitations or ont
engendré pour des millions de français
notamment travailleurs indépendants
l'allemagne comme bien d'autres pays a
ouvert depuis deux semaines restaurants
commerces pour pénaliser ainsi l'otan
dépendant à rebours de toute l'europe et
leur faire risquer la faillite le
déclassement avoir bien pire
vous devez avoir compris quelque chose
que personne d'autre n'a compris où ma
question est simple ce premier ministre
qu'avez-vous donc compris soyez à la
hauteur du sinistre au delà de telle ou
telle ambition de tel ou tel petit
calcul
nous voudrions être sûr que vous ferez
passer le sort des français qui
souffrent des lenteurs et carences
administratives au dessus de votre sort
personnel et des menaces judiciaires
potentiel être responsable
étymologiquement sait répondre cela
demande du courage mais c'est ainsi que
vous serez à la hauteur la souffrance
sociale croissante du peuple français
merci davance monsieur le premier
ministre pour votre réponse merci
monsieur le député la parole et à madame
si bête ndiaye secrétaire d'état porte
parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député sun forget je vous
remercie pour votre question qui me
permet de peut-être apporter un
éclairage sur ce qu'a été la politique
de ce gouvernement depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
à chaque instant nous avons fait le
choix de regarder ce qui était les
indicateurs sanitaires de nous appuyer
sur un rationnel le scientifique et
sanitaires pour prendre l'ensemble des
décisions qui ont été les nôtres que ce
soit en matière de doctrine d'emploi des
masques de doctrine de diffusion et
d'utilisation des tests c'est uniquement
sur ceux rationnel scientifique et
sanitaire peut nous avons fait les choix
qui ont été les nôtres en matière de
politique de santé publique et les
résultats sont au rendez-vous cette
épidémie que nul n'avait pu prévoir dans
l'ampleur qu'elle a prises nul à travers
le monde
nul à travers l'europe et
malheureusement aussi dans notre pays
nous y avons fait face vous y abonner
passe parce que nous avons su anticiper
l'adaptation de notre système de santé
parce que nous avons eu des personnels
soignants administratifs qui se sont
montrés à la hauteur de la tâche qui
était la leur nous avons su y faire face
aussi en matière économique car vous
connaissons les répercussions terribles
que cette crise sanitaire a pu avoir en
matière économique et sociale
c'est d'ailleurs parce que aussi nous
avions mené une politique depuis le
début du quinquennat lorsque notamment
vous étiez membre de cette majorité en
matière d'investissements en matière de
maîtrise de nos comptes publics que nous
avons été capables aujourd'hui de faire
face à cette crise les indicateurs
sanitaires aujourd'hui semble bien
orientées dans cette première phase de
déconfinement mais nous nous attachons à
être dans la prudence la prudence qui
nous permettra peut-être de passer une
seconde étape du déconfinement en
fonction de l'évolution de ses
indicateurs
sachez monsieur le député que ce
gouvernement a été déterminée dans
l'action et compte bien le rester je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à madame bénédicte taurine
je remercie ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités de
la santé j'en ai marre de voir les ports
crever de faim dans le pays de la bouffe
ces mots sont ceux de coluche en 1985
quand il crée les restos du coeur depuis
cette époque que la pauvreté a explosé
aujourd'hui elle touche 9 millions de
personnes dans la sixième puissance et
la plus riche au monde avec la crise
sanitaire à ce sont des millions de
personnes enfants étudiants
auto-entrepreneurs retraités qui sont en
précarité alimentaire et qui ne mangent
plus à leur faim
c'est en plus de la culpabilité et de la
honte de ne pas s'en sortir
l'obligation de recourir à l'aide
alimentaire avec des associations qui
sont débordées sur le site de votre
ministère j'ai lu que la lutte contre la
précarité alimentaire vise à favoriser
l'accès à une alimentation sûre
diversifiée de bonne qualité et en
quantité suffisante et c'est en fait
c'est bien de communiquer avec une jolie
photo mais dans les faits concrètement
ce que vous faites c'est que d'un côté
vous donner des milliards aux plus
riches et aux entreprises sans
contrepartie sociale de l'autre vous
faites de la charité vous féliciter de
donner 150 euros à des familles 100
euros pour un enfant ce qui au passage
équivaut à peu près à 1 euro par repas
par jour vous poussé l'indécence jusqu'à
proposer des guides pratiques pour se
nourrir avec un petit budget
est ce que vous considérez que c'est la
faute des gens s'ils ne peuvent pas se
nourrir avec quelques euros par jour et
ce qu'il faut leur expliquer comment
faire est-ce que c'est là toute votre
ambition politique que les gens se
débrouille pour survivre en leur
fournissant un guide et en comptant sur
des milliers de bénévoles pour qu'ils
arrivent à manger quand allez vous
réellement mettre en oeuvre une
politique de la solidarité
quand allez-vous faire en sorte de
partager réellement les richesses temps
allez vous encadrer les prix
alimentaires
parce que c'est du rôle du gouvernement
de faire en sorte que chacune et chacun
puisse vivre dignement d'un autre pays
merci madame le député la parole et
tamada me christelle d'ubs aux
supporters d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames émis
les députés mesdames les députés vous
avez raison la crise a eu un impact
considérable sur des milliers de
familles permettez moi juste de rappeler
quelques chiffres
en france l'aide alimentaire porté par
quatre grandes associations que tous les
français connaissent restos du coeur la
croix rouge secours populaire ou encore
les banques alimentaires sont des
associations qui gèrent la politique d'
aide alimentaire pour le compte de
l'état et pour répondre aux besoins de
l'ensemble des citoyens quand je dis le
compte de l'état parce que les
financements sont portés par l'état 115
millions d'euros financés par l'état et
une partie nécessaire de cet argent
pardon financée par les fonds européens
350 millions de dons de défiscalisation
par les dons des particuliers des
entreprises 250 millions aussi faut leur
ajouter portés par les collectivités
territoriales sans lequel la proximité
n'apporterait par leur quotidien
quand le monde dans la crise j'ai été au
quotidien et où présent au quotidien
auprès des associations pour coordonner
l'ensemble de leurs activités pour
qu'elles puissent être présentes sur
l'ensemble du territoire les
accompagnent et permettra une réserve
civique à des citoyens de s'engager à
leur côté pour continuer à être présent
quand nous avons vu qu'il y avait une
augmentation de la demande en lien avec
les associations
j'ai apporté un plan d'urgence de
soutien alimentaire de 39 millions
d'euros 39 millions d'euros c'est
entière de budget annuel rajouter sur la
table pour deux mois de crise
rajouter sur la table pour que les 25
millions puisse aller au directement aux
associations pour qu'elles puissent
acheter plus de denrées faire face à des
frais supplémentaires liés à la gestion
de la crise et 14 millions dont 4
millions dans les territoires
d'outre-mer pour permettre à cent mille
familles de bénéficier de cech d'urgence
alimentaire c'est-à-dire 2 9 millions de
familles qui vont pouvoir 2,9 millions
d'euros qui vont pouvoir bénéficier à
ces familles là en priorité et c'est
bien tous ensemble que nous trouverons
la solution par rapport à ce sujet et
l'état angolais encore plus loin c'est à
dire ne pas se substituer à ne pas se
substituer aux associations mais bien
leur faciliter le travail
parce que oui l'option n'est pas l'aide
alimentaire n'est pas une option en
france merci madame la ministre
la parole à madame josiane corneau
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
voter est un droit mais aussi un devoir
civique
il est le fondement de notre démocratie
comme le soulignait avec beaucoup de
profondeur le président jacques chirac
en 2002 le droit de vote n'est pas
l'expression d'une humeur c'est une
décision à l'égard de son pays à l'égard
de ses enfants
je tiens tout d'abord à féliciter
l'ensemble des maires des adjoints et
conseillers municipaux élus qui viennent
d'être installés qu'ils seront encore
dans les heures qui viennent
le premier tour des élections
municipales qui s'est déroulé au début
du confinement a fortement été perturbé
et enregistré un très faible taux de
participation pour un scrutin qui
d'habitude mobiliser les électeurs et
les électrices beaucoup de personnes
âgées notamment ne se sont pas déplacés
par peur de contracter le virus
il est aujourd'hui urgent d'offrir à
chaque citoyen la possibilité d'exprimer
son choix par correspondance
en complément du vote physique qu'il
n'est évidemment pas question de
remettre en cause et qui doit rester le
moyen principal de voter il pourrait
permettre à tous les électeurs qui ne
peuvent se rendre dans un bureau de vote
en raison d'un handicap pour des motifs
professionnels pour une raison sanitaire
comme nous la connaissons aujourd'hui
ou parce qu'ils sont absents le jour du
scrutin de s'exprimer et d'accomplir
ainsi leur devoir civique
alors que le vote par correspondance a
déjà fait ses preuves chez nos voisins
allemands ou suisses qu'il est déjà
autorisée pour les français établis hors
de france
allez vous monsieur le premier ministre
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
pour l'autoriser lors des élections
municipales du 28 juin prochain afin
d'avoir la participation la plus large
possible
je vous remercie merci mme la députée la
parole est à monsieur christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame la députée vous avez
raison un rendez vous important le 28
juin pour près de 16 millions de nos
concitoyens que nous devons accompagner
au mieux la décision du premier ministre
après consultation du conseil
scientifique après consultation de
l'ensemble des associations d'élus et
l'ensemble des partis politiques doit
maintenant être mises en oeuvre avec
plusieurs temps d'abord le temps de la
campagne sur lequel nous devons veiller
je recevrai demain l'ensemble des
représentants des partis politiques à ce
que le cadre sanitaire préconisé par le
conseil scientifique soit mise en oeuvre
et je sais le sens de la responsabilité
des élus quelle que soit leur étiquette
ou sans étiquette pour faire en sorte
que cette campagne puisse se dérouler au
lieu et puis il y a le jour du vote sur
lequel nous devons là aussi garantir à
chaque français qui viendra qui viendra
voter les conditions optimales d'un
point de vue sanitaire pour le
déroulement du vote
je pense par exemple au masque sur
lesquels l'état s'engagera aux côtés des
communes pour que chacun puisse en
bénéficier mais aussi à tout le process
de protection des assesseurs des membres
du bureau de vote mais aussi au moment
du dépouillement
autant de moments absolument essentiel
et puis il nous faut faciliter toutes
les conditions qui permettront dans un
cadre légal ou dans un cadre
réglementaire qui peut évoluer d'ici le
jour de l'élection qui permettra de
faire en sorte que un maximum de
français puissent voter le vote par
procuration et nous évoquerons demain
avec les actions devenues les modalités
de développement
le vote par correspondance qui est une
hypothèse qui avait été pratiqué en
france jusqu'en 1975 les parlementaires
de l'époque avait souhaité y mettre un
terme pour des raisons d' usage
frauduleux mais nous devons aujourd'hui
ne rien exclure sur ce sujet et c'est
dans cet esprit que nous travaillerons
demain avec les associations d'élus avec
les partis politiques et peut-être dans
les jours qui viennent avec vous pour
mettre en oeuvre la capac des capacités
nouvelles pour développer et garantir le
vote je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre le poursuivre
maintenant notre séance avait des
questions pourtant sur des thèmes
économiques et sociaux
la parole est à monsieur le président la
garde merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre lundi
prochain
l'indemnisation du chômage partiel
changes et notamment conduit à ce que
les entreprises participent puisqu'il ya
une reprise d'activité un peu plus à
leur financement mais surtout la semaine
prochaine la rentrée des classes va être
beaucoup plus généralisée d'abord pour
un certain nombre de collèges mais
également pour des enfants qui ne sont
pas venus les deux premières semaines en
école maternelle est en école
élémentaire mais dont on voit que le
nombre augmente pourquoi parce que les
salariés ont besoin de retrouver leur
travail de sauver leur entreprise ils
sont amenés par leur employeur à le
faire mais la capacité scolaire dans
beaucoup d'écoles dans des villages
comme dans des grandes villes
peut être atteinte assez rapidement et
donc l'école ne pourra pas accueillir
tout le monde
ma question est finalement qu il y aura
trois catégories ceux qui parmi les
parents ont choisi de ne pas remettre
leurs enfants à l'école c'est de leur
responsabilité c'est de leur choix et
j'imagine que ils n'auront pas le droit
au chômage partiel ou en tout cas à une
allocation de garde de leurs enfants
la deuxième catégorie c'est ce dont les
enfants seront à l'école et pourront
aller travailler
ils sortiront du dispositif par nature
du chômage partiel puisque ils
exerceront leur métier
la troisième catégorie et c'est celle
qui m'inquiète ce sont ceux qui vont
être accueillies de façon alternée à
l'école une semaine sur deux un jour sur
deux et je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez rassurer ces centaines de
milliers de parents de salariés qui
peuvent se retrouver à un moment donné
en difficulté d'abord pour faire valoir
leurs droits parce qu'il est difficile a
déclaré un jour sur deux une semaine sur
deux d'autant que ce n'est pas toujours
prévisibles monsieur le premier ministre
je pense que beaucoup de français
attendent de savoir comment ça
fonctionne à partir de la semaine
prochaine
lorsqu'ils veulent scolariser leurs
enfants mais que les communes les
départements ou les régions ne sont pas
en situation de le faire merci monsieur
le président la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le président monsieur le
président la garde
je réponds bien volontiers à votre
question qui est importante parce que
beaucoup de français se posent ces
sujets et alors elle est là
l'imbrication au fond au carrefour entre
les mesures qui ont été prises pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat
le maintien du contrat de travail entre
le salarié et l'entreprise alors même
que nous étions soumis à des situations
à une situation hors norme ou de chacun
étaient confinés où la reprise est très
lente donc le des mesures très
économique et puis les mesures cette
fois-ci sanitaires et pédagogique qui
permette la reprise de l'école dans des
conditions particulières c'est vrai dans
des conditions de reprise prudente et
progressive dans des conditions
différenciées en fonction des
territoires vous le savez puisque dans
les zones dites rouges les collèges
n'ont pas repris alors qu'ils ont repris
pour les 6e et 5e dans les autres dites
vertes
on est on est vraiment dans le
l'imbrication de ces deux sujets pour
aller rapidement à la réponse à laquelle
vous m'invitez notre objectif c'est de
faire en sorte d'abord de respecter très
strictement l'ensemble des consignes
sanitaires qui seront données pour la
reprise à l'école nous ne voulons
prendre aucun risque
nous sommes prudents il y à quelques
instants un député qui assis juste
derrière vous disait que nous étions
trop prudent je je n'ai aucun espoir
monsieur le président la garde de
convaincre la totalité de la population
française que nous sommes au bon rythme
certains nous trouverons toujours trop
prudent certains nous trouverons
toujours pas assez prudent c'est comme
ça mais ce que nous voulons c'est
respecter le plus strictement possible
les consignes sanitaires qui sont
données par les autorités compétentes
faire en sorte que la reprise des cours
pour les enfants pour les enseignants
pour l'ensemble de la communauté
pédagogique ne pose aucun problème et ça
n'est pas simple parce que parfois il y
as circulation du virus parce que
parfois les bâtiments se prête mal on le
sait à la reprise des cours en tout cas
moins bien la reprise des cours que dans
certains autres endroits
notre objectif est le suivant si les
indicateurs restent bien orientés et je
le dis là aussi avec prudence c'est une
décision qui sera prise je dis j'aurais
l'occasion de communiquer sur ce point
jeudi après midi
si les eaux si les indicateurs restent
bien orientés alors nous pourrons sans
doute organiser une ouverture un peu
plus vaste des écoles faire en sorte que
les règles sanitaires puisse s'adapter
toujours avec prudence mais s'adapter à
ces nouvelles conditions
ce qui permettra d'accueillir je
l'espère et encore une fois je dis si
les indicateurs restent bien orientées
plus d'élèves à l'école de faire en
sorte que
plus de professeurs reviennent savez
qu'il ya 50 % des professeurs qui sont
revenus assurés leur court physiquement
en présentiel et évidemment si on veut
accueillir plus et là il faut plus de
professeurs puissent revenir mais il
faut que ça se passe dans d'excellentes
conditions
si c'est le cas c'est un grand si mais
si c'est le cas alors le nombre de ceux
qui vont se trouver dans la situation
vous décrivez va mécaniquement diminuer
à partir du 2 juin mais pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient faire en sorte que leurs
enfants soient accueillis à l'école et
qu'ils ne pourraient pas voir leurs
enfants accueillis à l'école sauf pour
des raisons de capacité soit parce que
on ne peut plus les accueillir on ne
peut pas les accueillir à ce moment
alors pour cela et pour cela seulement
lorsqu'ils ont une attestation qui
permettra d'établir le fait que leur
enfant ne peut pas être accueillis ils
pourront continuer à bénéficier des
dispositions relatives au chômage
partiel c'est exactement ce que vous
avez indiquée il ya une deuxième
question pratique qui est plus délicate
parce qu'elle dépend beaucoup des
communautés pédagogique c'est de savoir
comment se passe cette reprise
c'est vrai que si on alterne chaque jour
les enfants qui viennent à l'école
il est très délicat pour les parents
surtout si les enfants sont très jeunes
de s'organiser vis-à-vis de leur
employeur
ça peut même devenir assez vite
redoutable certains pourront le faire
mais tout le monde ne pourra pas alors
dans ce cas là il faut que nous soyons
capables d'engager le débat avec les
communautés pédagogique avec les
directeurs d'école avec les enseignants
pour faire en sorte de prendre en compte
cette contrainte une contrainte réelle
elle est parfaitement entendable de
toute personne raisonnable peut
parfaitement comprendre que ça a un sens
de faire en sorte que l'ensemble du
système productif puisse repartir c'est
l'intérêt collectif
c'est l'intérêt du pays et on peut
probablement avec de la bonne foi avec
de la bonne volonté
faire en sorte que cet échange
permettent de régler la question c'est
le pari que nous faisons c'est un pari
qui n'a rien à voir avec une règle
nationale est mise et tout à voir avec
la capacité des acteurs locaux directeur
d'école mère professeur de s'entendre et
de trouver la bonne solution et je fais
le pari de cette confiance
merci monsieur le premier ministre je
pose dans la garde
monsieur le premier ministre vous
remercie de la réponse j'ai deux choses
à dire la première c'est qu'il serait
quand même bien qu'une directive
nationale favorisant une semaine sur
deux soit donnée ça aiderait au dialogue
et la deuxième c'est si vous élargissez
la capacité d'accueil scolaire la
semaine prochaine laisser une semaine de
délai aux communes aux départements pour
s'adapter
c'est déjà assez compliqué comme ça on
peut pas le faire la dernière minute
vous l'annoncé jeudi laisser leur un peu
de temps merci monsieur le président la
parole est à monsieur guillaume garot
maire merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre la crise
économique qui est devant nous sera rude
avec le risque évident d'un chômage
massif
nous devons tirer toutes les leçons de
la crise de 2008 est donc tout ce qu'il
ira dans le sens de d'un soutien à
l'investissement et à la consommation
sera positif c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous saluons l'initiative
franco-allemande pour que l'europe
accompagne la relance par les états mais
je veux le dire aussi
l'argent public ne peut pas être donnée
sans contrepartie nous devons éviter au
maximum les licenciements et préserver
notre capacité à produire si tu
apprécies tu usines après usine en
répondant aux nouvelles exigences
économiques numérique et écologique
nous attendons cet après midi les
annonces du président de la république
pour le secteur automobile
mais je vais vous le dire nous sommes
d'ores et déjà inquiets de l'attitude du
gouvernement face aux projets de renault
vous semblez accepter la fermeture de
certains sites
alors même que le constructeur va
bénéficier des prêts garantis par l'état
à hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros
monsieur le premier ministre l'état
actionnaire a une responsabilité
particulière qu'il doit assumer et notre
proposition
elle tient en quatre points premièrement
garantir le maintien dans l'emploi des
salariés en articulant activités et
formation deuxièmement sauvegarder les
sites en relocalisant aux besoins
certaines lignes de production
aujourd'hui installés dans des pays qui
pratiquent ce qu'on appelle le dumping
social
troisièmement prendre résolument le
virage vers les motorisations plus
sobres plus propre et en particulier
bien sur l'électrique pour aller sans
attendre vers une industrie décarbonée
enfin quatrièmement créer un mécanisme
de solidarité de filières avec les sous
traitants avec les équilibres si je
perds pas et la parole à madame agnès
pannier une arche et secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député garrot à la question
que vous posez elle est au coeur de nos
préoccupations
c'est de savoir comment nous allons
accompagner les entreprises pour
permettre aux salariés de ces
entreprises de traverser cette crise qui
est devant nous fout puisque derrière
les entreprises c'est pas ces
établissements c'est les emplois les
compétences les capacités de production
pour lequel nous luttons et
effectivement vous proposer quatre
points dans votre démarche et je veux
illustrer chacun de ces points
le premier point c'est la transition
écologique énergétique elle est au coeur
des prêts garantis par l'état que nous
signons elle est au coeur des
discussions que nous avons et je ne peux
donner que l'exemple d'air france
lorsque nous discutons par exemple une
contribution de plusieurs milliards
d'euros il ya encore quelques semaines
et vous avez raison c'est une nécessité
car c'est un élément qui permettra de
transformer notre industrie de la rendre
plus compétitive
la deuxième chose vous parler des
compétences et je vous rejoins sur le
fait qu'il va falloir mettre le paquet
sur la formation c'est les plans sur
lequel travaille muriel pénicaud qui va
falloir mettre le paquet sur la
protection des savoirs faire et en
particulier en r&d et c'est un des
éléments que retiendront notamment pour
le plan aéronautique et également pour
le plan automobile
la troisième chose c'est d'éviter le
dumping social pour éviter le dumping
social
il y à deux voies la première c'est
effectivement de savoir faire
reconnaître nos qualités
environnementales et les qualités
sociales de nos productions
c'est le mécanisme d'inclusion carbone
que nous demanderons à la commission
européenne de mettre en place c'est le
travail que nous faisons sur la
valorisation de d'un niveau j'irai
sociale minimale au niveau européen mais
c'est également une question de
compétitivité c'est à dire nous devons
aussi balayer devant notre porte c'est
ce que nous essayons de faire par
exemple en regardant les impôts de
production enfin le dernier élément la
solidarité croyait bien que c'est au
coeur du plan automobile
les sous traitants et donneurs d'ordre
la parole est à monsieur jean paul
dufrègne oui monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances l'économie
mondiale est dévastée et notre pays
n'échappe pas à cette catastrophe de
multiples entreprises notamment les plus
petites de nombreux artisans commerçants
ou professions libérales connaissent des
difficultés beaucoup ne s'en relèveront
pas malgré les mesures mises en place et
que nous avons soutenu de nombreux
français vont prendre le chemin de pôle
emploi la pauvreté va s'enraciner un peu
plus jamais la notion de solidarité n'a
été aussi nécessaire dans notre pays si
nous voulons endiguer cette situation et
relever la france
le défi est grand mais nous avons les
moyens d'y répondre
il faut une répartition des richesses
qui passe à la fois par une contribution
des gros patrimoines et une imposition
mieux proportionné notamment pour les
revenus élevés et les grands groupes
bénéficiaires qui pour certains
continuent de distribuer des dividendes
l'économiste et prix nobel esther duflo
a récemment plaidé pour le retour de
l'impôt sur la fortune
vous avez beau dire et redire que cet
impôt est un impôt du siècle dernier
vos mots sonnent faux dans le contexte
actuel ce sont des mots du passé et vos
schémas sont aujourd'hui dépassés vous
appeler à la mobilisation générale
nous appelons à la mobilisation de tous
sans exception nous ne sommes pas là
pour régler des comptes
nous sommes là pour les rétablir comment
justifier que dans un tel contexte
certains ne seraient pas mis à juste
contribution
la question n'est même plus de savoir
s'il faut le faire mais quand et comment
c'est pourquoi nous défendrons
prochainement une proposition de loi
pour que hauts revenus et aux
patrimoines contribue plus à l'effort de
solidarité nationale
monsieur le ministre etes-vous enfin
convaincu comme une écrasante majorité
des français
que ce sujet doit être mis sur la table
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame agnès pannier rina chez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
dufrègne nous sommes au tout début de la
reprise économique
et vous voulez déjà taxé les français
mais je crois que nous n'y sommes pas du
tout l'enjeu n'est pas d'augmenter les
impôts dans un pays où la fiscalité est
la plus élevée d'europe
l'enjeu c'est d'accompagner les
entreprises de faire en sorte de
préserver les compétences
voilà où elle combat aujourd'hui c'est
de préserver la croissance à moyen terme
qui seule est garante d'un partage des
richesses équilibré voilà dans quelle
direction nous devons aller et pourquoi
pourquoi nous avons pendant le projet de
loi de finances 2011 a baissé les impôts
baisser les impôts sur les classes
moyennes sur les classes populaires avec
une baisse de 5 milliards d'euros de
l'impôt sur le revenu des personnes
physiques pourquoi nous avons baissé la
taxe d'habitation voire supprimée pour
les 80 % de français les plus modestes
précisément pour avoir cette meilleure
répartition des impôts mais ce n'est pas
en retirant quelque chose à certains que
vous allez améliorer la situation
aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est la croissance
c'est la croissance structurelle et
c'est la reprise économique
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur michel vialay monsieur le
premier ministre le secteur de mobiles
ce sont près d'un million d'emplois au
coeur de nos régions
la crise lui fait subir un choc violent
et la reprise sera lente puisque 51% des
français prévoit de reporter l'achat de
leur voiture
aujourd'hui la survie de l'industrie
automobile est en jeu notre vrai défi et
d'inventer la mobilité du futur et y
investir massivement et stratégique pour
notre pays car l'avenir de ces
prochaines années conjuguera véhicule
autonome et décarbonée mais vous le
savez l'actualité immédiate et celles du
groupe renault dont on connaissait déjà
les difficultés économiques et de
gouvernance et qui vient d'annoncer un
plan de restructuration qui impacterait
notamment le site de flins emblématique
de la voiture électrique avec fable la
fabrication de la zoé au coeur des
yvelines sous l'impulsion son président
pierre bédier les yvelines ont investi
depuis plusieurs années dans le secteur
automobile et notamment pour y
accueillir un pôle r&d sur le véhicule
de demain et il est mobilisé pour
accroître son investissement notamment
au profit de la formation et de
l'accompagnement des salariés mais vous
le savez cela ne peut suffire
bien sûr un plan d'action pour
l'automobile sera annoncée vendredi
prochain et vous avez indiqué vous-même
que l'état n'acceptera pas un plan de
restructuration synonyme de
désindustrialisation et qui sera
intransigeant quant à la préservation
des sites france mais au delà des
intentions et des promesses
cela appelle plusieurs questions sur la
réalité vos engagements à l'identique
d'autres grands pays
le gouvernement soutiendra t-il
massivement les investissements des
entreprises du secteur automobile dans
la recherche mais aussi dans la
transformation de leur outil industriel
nécessaire pour fabriquer des véhicules
autonomes et décarbonées le gouvernement
aura-t-il la volonté d'accompagner
massivement la formation qui garantira à
tous les salariés leur employabilité
face à la mutation profonde des emplois
qui s'annonce
l'état qui détient directement 15 % du
capital de renault et 21,5 pour sont
aussi inclus ses participations au
capital d autres actionnaires
s'engage-t-il à garantir le maintien du
site de flins pour en faire le point de
départ de la stratégie de transformation
vers plus de durabilité les emplois et
la transition écologique sont
compatibles il faut s'en donner les
moyen merci monsieur débuté la parole
est à madame agnès pannier rue nash et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vial et je veux excuser ici bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie qui est
aux côtés du président de la république
en visite sur le site de valeo
témoignage de sa forte implication dans
l'élaboration du plan automobile qui
sera présenté par le président la
république d'ici une petite heure et je
crois que vous aurez toutes les réponses
à la question que vous avez posé je veux
revenir un instant sur l'avenir de
renault
la crise que nous traversons année sans
précédant l'impact est important sur
l'automobile je veux rappeler ici les
chiffres en avril les chiffres
d'affaires chute de plus de 80% en
france et le marché devrait s'établir à
en retrait de 30% par rapport à l'année
dernière
tout ça c'est autant de chiffre
d'affaires qui monteront qui manqueront
aux entreprises pour des industries dans
les marges sont structurellement faible
c'est un enjeu de surge de survie qui se
joue c'est le cas pour renault qui a
abordé cette crise en situation de
fragilité vous le saviez
puisque la directrice générale par
intérim avait fait état en février 2019
de la situation délicate de renault à un
moment de ralentissement du marché
mondial
dans ce contexte l'état va prendre ses
responsabilités en mettant en place un
plan de soutien puissant à l'automobile
puissant et transformant puisque pour
répondre à vos questions
oui il sera orienté sur la transition
écologique et énergétique et visera à
permettre aux motorisations électriques
de se développer beaucoup plus
rapidement
oui il sera orienté pour améliorer
l'appareil productif français et faire
en sorte que nous basculions enfin dans
l' usine du futur
et oui il veillera à équilibrer les
relations entre donneurs d'ordre et sous
traitants
l'etat sera aussi un actionnaire
responsable et exigeant comme il l'a été
ces dernières semaines et ces derniers
mois et dans ce cadre nous ouvrons le
point dans les prochaines semaines
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame véronique rio ton merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre en
charge des personnes handicapées
tout au long de la crise sanitaire nous
avons exprimé notre reconnaissance
vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont contribué à la
lutte contre le virus
je souhaite aujourd'hui rendre un
hommage tout particulier aux entreprises
adaptées aux esat qui par leur modèle
inclusif permettent à des personnes en
situation de handicap d'accéder à
l'emploi d'être accompagnés dans leur
projet professionnel
ces établissements se sont
remarquablement engagée dans la gestion
de la crise et ont été mobilisés comme
par exemple dans la production de
masques
l'atelier à des tp en haute savoie leur
contribution peut être d'autant plus
salué qu'en plus d'être un pacte
économiquement
celles ci ont été fragilisés par un
absentéisme dû à l'arrêt de travail
dérogatoires pour les personnes
vulnérables
aujourd'hui les personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap ont besoin plus
que jamais d'un soutien d'insertion dans
l'emploi de la part de l'état une étude
ifop montre que les impacts
psychologiques et économiques de la
crise pour 68% de ces personnes qui ont
développé une inquiétude face à leur
propre avenir
face aux inégalités croisé tels que nous
les observons ici faciliter l'inclusion
doit être prévu à la fois dans les
mesures de déconfinement est à la fois
dans le plan de relance
ces mesures doivent être destinées aux
entreprises adaptées évidemment mais
surtout au marché ordinaire pour que
toutes les entreprises puissent mettre
en oeuvre des solutions de relance plus
inclusive nous pourrons faire se
rencontrer des personnes en situation de
handicap et des professionnels lors du
prochain duo dès cet automne et les
compétences des personnes en situation
de handicap sont une chance il faut
aider les parcours professionnels à se
déployer dans toute notre économie
pouvez vous nous indiquer madame la
ministre quelles mesures économiques
seront prises pour répondre à ces enjeux
et un plan sectoriel propre à
l'inclusion est il envisagé dans le plan
de relance pour une société plus
solidaire
merci
les buts et la parole est à madame
sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état chargé
des personnes handicapées
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
griottons valoriser les compétences des
personnes handicapées c'est au coeur du
projet que nous portons depuis trois ans
avec muriel pénicaud et olivier du soft
ce n'est pas un mantra j'étais la
semaine dernière dans une entreprise
adaptée de la paix france handicap à
evreux pour saluer la capacité
d'innovation et d'adaptation du secteur
et sa mobilisation en pleine crise pour
la production de masques sociale et
performance ce n'est pas antinomique
la crise aura des effets majeurs sur
l'économie nous devons veiller à ce que
les personnes handicapées déjà deux fois
plus au chômage que les autres en soient
protégés je lui ai indiqué clairement il
ne saurait y avoir dans le cadre de la
reprise d'activité de discriminations
liées au handicap grâce aux cncph chaque
fiche conseil métier publié sur le
ministère du travail inclut un encart
dédié il nous faut amplifier la
mobilisation
je lui ai dit début mai aux
organisations syndicales et patronales
pour que le dialogue social social porte
cette dynamique je le dis aussi aux
entreprises qui devront exercer leur
responsabilité sociétale et notamment
toutes celles qui se sont engagés dans
le manifeste inclusion des aides de
l'agefiph et du fpi php ont été adaptés
et continueront à l'être pour encourager
les aménagements nécessaires de poste ou
le télétravail quand il est possible je
souligne aussi que les textes attaché à
la loi fonction publique sont désormais
publiés avec des avancées très
importantes pour les personnes
handicapées qu'il s'agisse d'entrée ou
de faire carrière dans nos
administrations
aussi dès le confinement j'ai soutenu
les esat puisque l'état assure le
paiement de la totalité du salaire des
travailleurs des entreprises adaptées
ont elles pu activer l'activité
partielle ainsi que les autres
dispositifs de droit commun mais elles
ont registre en effet des baisses de
chiffre d'affaires importantes
c'est pour ça qu'avec muriel pénicaud et
thibaut guide il au commissaire à
l'inclusion
nous travaillons aux moyens
d'accompagner ses reprises mais plus
globalement d'inciter à inscrire
l'emploi des personnes handicapées dans
les opportunités de développement des
filières de production
on plus local plus durable solidaire et
responsable
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur dino cinieri merci ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
dès le 15 mars les entrepreneurs du
secteur la restauration l'hôtellerie ont
été obligées de fermer leurs
établissements
certains ont pu maintenir une vente à
emporter dans des conditions complexes
pour respecter les gestes barrière mais
dans les territoires ruraux cela n'a pas
suffi n'a pas été possible pour les
employeurs et les salariés la situation
est dramatique
en effet les aides du fonds de
solidarité n'ont pas été suffisantes
pour payer les charges des loyers et des
fournisseurs avec mes collègues députés
du groupe l'est républicain
nous avons demandé à plusieurs reprises
des annulations de charges sociales et
fiscales massives de mars à juin
notamment pour les cafés restaurants
mais une fois de plus je premier
ministre n'avait pas écouté
aujourd'hui ces commerçants ne savent
toujours pas s'ils pourront rouvrir le 2
juin et dans quelles conditions les
territoires ruraux ne pourront pas
attirer les visiteurs
si ce secteur ne peut pas reprendre son
activité
c'est toute l'économie de nos villes et
villages qui risque d'être frappée de
plein fouet à la proche de l'été le
premier ministre vous demander aux
français de rester en france pour les
vacances mais à quand allez vous
permettre aux professionnels du tourisme
de rouvrir leur établissement sans hôtel
st camping sans gîtes ruraux sans
restaurant sans café
comment voulez-vous sérieusement
envisagé que les français préparent
aujourd'hui leurs vacances d'été
merci chers collègues pour la parole
était madame agnès pannier oui mais
après
si vous voulez lui répondre bien qu'elle
commence donc avant que le député de
vous répondre
allez-y madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député cinieri j'aurais
envie de vous renvoyer au dossier de
presse du plan tourisme qui a été publié
le 14 mai dernier ça fait une bonne
semaine peut-être même deux qu'il est
disponible et qu'il vous permettra de
voir en premier lieu que l'annulation
des charges sociales et fiscales que
vous appelez de vos voeux a bien été
décidé que 14 milliards d'euros
d'accompagnement sont disponibles pour
cette filière très importante
je veux également rappelé que les hôtels
peuvent ouvrir
d'ailleurs ils n'ont jamais été
administrativement fermées
je veux également dire que le premier
ministre a indiqué aux français qu'ils
pouvaient réserver leurs vacances dans
la mesure où ils seraient remboursés si
d'aventuré des éléments sanitaires nous
amener à prendre des décisions qui
allaient contre ses déplacements enfin
comme vous le savez jeudi et en accord
avec notre démarche qui est une démarche
méthodologique qui vise à prendre des
décisions fondées sur des éléments de
fait des rationalités nous de
confirmeront l'ouverture des restaurants
cafés à partir du 2 juin en précisant
dans quelle zone c'est ouverture auront
lieu de manière à le faire dans des
conditions sanitaires irréprochable et
je crois que c'est ça qu'attendent les
français
donc je veux vous rassurer ici je crois
que l'engagement du gouvernement pour la
filière tourisme est extrêmement fort
qu'ils les décisions étaient prises en
temps et en heure si je le compare aux
plans qui sont aujourd'hui élaboré au
plan international nous avons plutôt de
l'avant ce plutôt un plan plus puissant
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui nos
annonceurs nos interlocuteurs l'ont bien
reconnu je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
député
oui madame la manua ministre je
souhaitais avoir une date
vous me donnez le 2 juin j'espère que de
juin sera ferme et définitif et que je
ne suis pas journaliste donc je ne suis
pas au fait est-ce que de ce candidat
ils ont par contre il ya d'autres
questions qui restent sans réponse
moi j'aimerais monsieur le premier
ministre que vous répondiez aux français
qui sont dans le rouge bien le 20 du
mois qui s'inquiètent pour leur emploi
mais aussi aux inquiétudes et retraités
dans le pouvoir d'achat est en berne aux
assistants de vie scolaire qui ne savent
pas commun etc ans se passera la rentrée
aux étudiants qui devraient passer des
concours aux parents qu'ils doivent
aller travailler tout en assurant la
scolarité de leurs enfants
merci beaucoup la parole à monsieur
bruno myle yens merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie et des finances un à la
ministre hasard du calendrier
je me suis rendu sur le site de renault
flins situé dans ma circonscription pour
une visite consacrée à la reprise de
l'activité au lendemain d'une
information selon laquelle cette usine
pourrait fermer avec la crise sanitaire
le marché automobile français s'est
effondré de 70% mars de 90 % en avril
sur l'année les ventes pourraient chuter
de 20% en europe et 30 % en france
l'automobile représente 400 mille
emplois industriels directes et 900
milles avec les services hors de 40000 à
50000 postes sont menacés et 30% des
entreprises risquent la faillite sur le
conseil national des professions de
l'automobile premières victimes
identifiées
renault qui sollicite un prêt de 5
milliards d'euros garanti par l'état et
qui s'apprête à annoncer les contours
d'un plan d'économies de 2 milliards
d'euros
le présent la république annoncera ce
jour nous dit-on un plan relatif à la
souveraineté industrielle à la
transition vers les véhicules propres et
à la préservation de la compétitivité du
secteur
ces annonces sont très attendus vous
connaissez l'engagement de notre groupe
en faveur de la transition écologique et
énergétique du pays des mobilités
durables et de l'emploi industriel au
coeur des territoires
après la crise financière de 2008 les
contreparties sur l'emploi exigé par
l'état n'avait pas empêché une vague
massive de délocalisation le monde
d'après s'il doit exister ne peut
commencer de la sorte
madame la ministre pouvait nous nous
affirmer que le
vernement imposer des contreparties à
l'octroi de ce prêt et nous dire si
renault prendra des engagements forts
pour localiser et préservés en france
les emplois liés aux véhicules
électriques
quel avenir pour les trois sites menacés
quel avenir pour la zoé électrique qui
fait vivre à flins 2600 salariés quelle
mesure le gouvernement entend qu'il
prendre en faveur du secteur automobile
français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame agnès pannier une hache et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
1000 yens merci pour votre question je
sais votre attachement à l'industrie et
je sais votre attachement au site de
flins vous étiez encore récemment et je
sais aussi votre soutien exigeant aux
gouvernements pour que les meilleures
mesures soient prises pour accompagner
renault dans cette passe difficile car
la crise que nous traversons c'est une
crise qui est sans égal pour
l'automobile c'est une crise qui se
traduit par l'effondrement des ventes
c'est une crise qui se déroule dans un
contexte de transformation de la filière
automobile puisqu'il faut à la fois
venir au secours enfin en tout cas à
préserver l'activité est en même temps
transformé tout la filière avec la
voiture électrique et la voiture
connectée ce qui exige des
investissements extrêmement important
comme vous le savez nous avons été
particulièrement actifs sur le sujet de
l'automobile ces dernières années au
travers du contrat stratégique de
filière en mettant en place les
fondements de la transition écologique
énergétique dans l'automobile c'est cet
airbus de la patrie qui permet de
fabriquer en france 40% de la valeur des
voitures électriques à savoir les
cellules et la batterie et c'est ce
projet est entraîne de continuer à se
poursuivre et nous aurons en france
une première usine de batteries dans les
prochains mois voilà la première réponse
que je peux vous faire le plan
d'accompagnement ira dans cette
direction et je veux d'abord vous dire
que renault va rejoindre ce projet de
d'airbus de la batterie montrant
justement cet engagement au service de
la transition écologique que avec le
plan qu'elle va annoncer le président de
la république c'est un nouveau chapitre
nous allons ouvrir en matière
d'industrie automobile un chapitre qui
sera orienté vers l'amélioration de la
productivité notre outil en soutenant
l'investissement dans l' usine du futur
dans la consolidation de la filière dans
l'amélioration de la réponse et
l'électrique est justement en
relocalisant le maximum d'éléments du
moteur et de la traction électrique au
travers des différents sous traitants et
merci votre honneur
la parole est à monsieur sébastien jumel
[Applaudissements]
le premier ministre renault en normandie
ça nous cause alpine que j'ai exposé
dans la cour de l'hôtel de matignon
ça vous cause en 15 ans la fière
automobile a perdu 120 mille emplois
25000 pour la marque au losange sur la
même période avec l'état actionnaire on
a continué à délocaliser twingo mégane
clio et une part importante de
l'ingénierie 17 % des véhicules de
particuliers sont aujourd'hui produits
en france contre 54% en 2004 les causes
de ces difficultés sont multiples course
à la rentabilité
erreur stratégique sur le positionnement
gamme problèmes de gouvernance au sein
de l'alliance
jusqu aux tribulations de carlos ghosn
la crise sanitaire a accentué évidemment
ce phénomène avec une chute brutale des
ventes et l'annoncé du plan de deux
milliards d'euros d'économies avec
quatre fermetures envisagées sur les
sites de choisy de la fonderie de
bretagne de flins et dale pied ne font
l'effet d'une bombe
alors que dans quelques minutes le
président de la république va dévoiler
un plan massif de primes à l'achat pour
des véhicules plus propres d'impro
langard antilles par l'état de 5
milliards d'euros
s'il n'y a pas de contrepartie en terme
de préservation de savoir faire et de
contreparties en termes de préservation
de sites cela aura l'effet d'un désastre
économique et social
un renoncement productif à renoncement
politique proche de celui de vilvorde
au moment où il y à émergence d'une
nouvelle souveraineté industrielle
plébiscité par les français monsieur le
premier ministre
alpine est le symbole du made in france
possible vous connaissez mon engagement
et celui des élus normands pour ce my
dinh diem pour ce lieu de travail
d'orfèvre à dimension humaine pour ce
lieu qui démontre que la haute
technologie
le premium sont possibles en france
allez-vous avoir la volonté politique
d'un carnet l'état stratégie qui
protègent ou allez vous renoncer
voilà c'est sensuel qui ont été la
parole est à madame agnès pannier une
hache et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jumelles je connais votre attachement au
site de dieppe je connais la fierté des
normands pour la fabrication de l'alpine
c'est une charte est d'ailleurs bien
légitime car c'est un bijou
technologique que cette voiture je les
ai déjà indiqué renaud est dans une
situation critique et nous prenons nos
responsabilités nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour accompagner cette
entreprise et faire en sorte qu'elle
passe le cap et qu'elle passe pas le cap
à tout prix mais quelqu'un me passe le
cap en préservant au maximum sa
recherche et développement les sites
installés en france et en exigeant
effectivement des contreparties sur la
transition écologique énergétique et sur
des relocalisations car vous l'avez très
bien dit des voitures qui ont été
délocalisés ces dernières années il y en
a beaucoup et beaucoup sur les petits
modèles
or ce sont les modèles que les français
sachent est le plus souvent en pensant
acheter une voiture française s'il
achète une marque française le travail
que nous faisons aujourd'hui c'est de
regarder quels sont les éléments de ces
chaînes de valeur que nous pouvons
réimplanté en france et où nous sommes
compétitifs car les français ne sont pas
prêts à payer 1000 euros de plus le même
modèle de voiture que celui qui est
aujourd'hui fabriquées en slovaquie en
pologne et en espagne
malheureusement le marché le 10 et
et donc prolongé aujourd'hui que nous
avons c'est d'accompagner cette montée
en compétitivité c'est à dire en faisant
en sorte de transformer non seulement
renommée l'ensemble de la filière
automobile
en investissant massivement dans
l'appareil productif
les machines à commandes numériques les
robots les kobo tous ces éléments qui
nous rendront plus efficace et qui
permettront de rattraper le gap et on
relocalise ans les productions qui sont
celles du futur c'est à dire celle de la
traction électrique et c'est tout
l'enjeu du plan qu'annoncera le
président de la république dans les
prochaines minutes
merci madame la ministre la parole de
monsieur charles de la verpillière
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il est urgent de
finaliser le plan de soutien de
l'industrie aéronautique que votre
ministre de l'économie a promis pour
avant le 1er juillet oui c'est urgent
car la construction aéronautique
française va connaître une crise
terrible et durable probablement
jusqu'en 2022 en raison de la cessation
des commandes de la chute des commandes
passées par les compagnies aériennes
pour la france
le sauvetage de notre industrie
aéronautique est absolument vital pour
trois raisons premièrement le poids
économique de ce secteur poids
économique et social considérable car la
filière emploie cent mille personnes le
plus souvent très qualifiés
deuxièmement la contribution très
importante du secteur à notre balance
commerciale puisqu'il a dégagé un
excédent de 34 milliards d'euros en 2019
enfin c'est un secteur stratégique qu'il
nous faut absolument protégé pour
maintenir notre souveraineté
particulièrement dans le domaine de
l'aviation militaire et de l'espace
monsieur le premier ministre chaque jour
compte où en êtes vous merci monsieur le
député
la parole est à madame agnès pannier
rina chez secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
verpillière vous avez raison de
souligner l'importance de l'industrie
aéronautique en france l'industrie
aéronautique c'est 300000 emplois si on
prend l'ensemble de la filière c'est
1200 entreprises et surtout une
technologie de pointe qui fait que la
france est aujourd'hui le seul pays avec
les états unis à pouvoir construire un
avion de a à z
cet avantage compétitif il ne faut pas
le perdre
or la situation actuelle est très
difficile très difficile parce que
l'aviation commerciale et tard été très
difficile parce que les compagnies
aériennes et pas seulement air france
doivent aujourd'hui faire face à des
risques de faillite et que les grands
états sont en train de regarder si elles
vont venir au secours de leur compagnie
à quel prix et avec quel impact sur les
plans d'investissement le ministère de
l'économie et des finances s'est
mobilisée nous sommes mobilisés pour
accompagner la mise en place du plan
d'urgence
le redémarrage des sites français dans
des conditions sanitaires irréprochable
et nous l'avons démarrer dès avant le
déconfinement je dirais même bien avant
et nous sommes aujourd'hui effectivement
en train de travailler sur un plan de
soutien à l'aéronautique ce plan de
soutien il sera annoncé dans les quinze
premiers jours de juin
il est aujourd'hui l'objet de
concertations avec les sous traitants
avec les donneurs d'ordre avec les
régions car elles ont un rôle important
à jouer en occitanie en nouvelles
aquitaine pour ne citer que ces deux
régions mais il n'y en a également
d'autres effectivement les hauts de
france et nous allons travailler à faire
en sorte de préserver trois choses la
première chose c'est d'utiliser le
levier de la transition écologique
énergétique pour soutenir la filière
parce que c'est dans des projets de
l'avion de demain de l'avion aussi
décarbonés que possible du biocarburant
que nous pourrons mobiliser les
ressources de r&d qui sont aujourd'hui
de grande qualité et qui n'ont plus de
programmes pour travailler c'est
également un accompagnement donneur
d'ordre sous traitant avec une
solidarité qui doit être très forte dans
la filière
c'est enfin la préservation des
compétences sur lesquels nous allons
travailler
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
député là nous dise j'ai l'impression
que vous ne savez pas très bien quoi
mettre dans ce plan de soutien
alors je vais vous donner quelques idées
premièrement maintenir un dispositif
spécifique de chômage partiel prolongé
autant qu'il le faudra deuxièmement
anticipée dès le budget 2010 21 des
commandes prévues par la loi de
programmation militaire c'est un levier
qu'il faut absolument active et
troisièmement créer un fonds
d'investissement rassemblant l'état et
les grands industriels pour éviter les
prises de contrôle par des prédateurs
étrangers
et quatrièmement un mécanisme spécifique
des de financement de la recherche pour
que nos entreprises restent dans le
peloton de tête mondial et vous avez
bien fait de le rappeler
voilà quelques inertie madame la musique
vous en inspirer la parole à monsieur
stéphane de vie merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
les conséquences économiques de la crise
sanitaire mondiale que nous traversons
sont dramatiques sur tout le spectre
industriel mais notamment cela vient
d'être dit sur celui de l'aéronautique
la chute du trafic aérien inédite depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale met en péril
la plupart des compagnies aériennes et
par effet domino toute la filière de
construction d'avions
l'annulation ou le report de commandes
d'appareils conjuguée à la résurgence
opportune du marché de l'occasion font
chuter les cadences de production
d'appareils neufs qui rythment les
ateliers des constructeurs et des sous
traitants
l'impact immédiat de cette pandémie
contraste avec le temps long qui sera
nécessaire pour retrouver une spirale
positive de développement
les fabrications mensuel de l'a320 passe
ainsi pour illustrer concrètement mon
propos de 60 à 40 appareils
cette baisse qui affecte toute la gamme
des aéronefs civils d'airbus pourrait
être selon certains spécialistes encore
plus conséquente l'art aux dimensions
des capacités industrielles qui en
résultent va générer de massive et
rapide suppressions d'emplois dans la
région d'albert berceau historique de
l'aéronautique avec près de 3000 emplois
directs cela se traduira par la faim
programme
du recours à l'intérim une réduction
drastique de la sous-traitance et du
chômage partiel pour les compagnons de
l'entreprise concernée cette période
mortifère va donc impacter terriblement
sur le plan économique et sur le plan
social
tous les territoires avec plusieurs
centaines d'emplois menacés la
disparition inéluctable d'établissement
renommés pour leur savoir faire
le temps presse car le risque
d'effondrement de notre excellence
aéronautique est une hypothèse glaçante
mais réelle le risque d'effondrement de
notre excellence aéronautique je le
répète est une hypothèse glaçante mais
réelle il est urgent de mettre en place
sous l'égide de l'état une cellule de
crise dans les territoires impactés
réunissant les acteurs industriels les
partenaires sociaux et les élus
concernés
vous avez annoncé le 18 mai dernier
qu'un plan sectoriel de soutien à la
filière aéronautique à être mise en
place
pouvons-nous en connaître les premières
orientations et allez vous associez les
parlementaires à cette réflexion
tous les parlementaires et pas
uniquement certains de haute garonne
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame agnès pannier village et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député d'amy d'abord je veux vous
rassurer dans le cadre du plan d'urgence
il y a déjà des cellules d'urgence déjà
des cellules d'urgence qui examine la
situation des entreprises et pas
seulement celles du secteur aéronautique
avec les élus locaux et qui les
accompagnent pour s'assurer qu'elle est
justement ne soit pas pris dans une
situation de déposer le bilan
je veux également vous assurer parce que
j'ai entendu des choses sur des actes
prédateur sur des entreprises qui
seraient des fleurons industriels de
notre pays nous n'avons pas attendu le
plan aéronautique ou tout autre plan
pour renforcer notre dispositif
d'investissement étrangers en france et
de contrôle qui nous permet justement de
faire droit à nos intérêts et de faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas d'acte de
présentation de cette nature je précise
d'ailleurs qu'au delà de ça
de longue date le plan les pardons et
fonds d'investissements spécifiques au
secteur aéronautique sont accompagnés
par bpi france la date de 2008 avec
assez de management et bpi est toujours
partie prenante de ces fonds donc là
aussi ce sont d'ores et déjà des mesures
qui existent pour répondre à votre
question est comme gelée indiqué à votre
collègue notre plan il repose sur trois
piliers un premier pilier qui est
effectivement l'accompagnement dans la
transition écologique énergétique parce
que ce sont des leviers pour soutenir la
r&d et faire en sorte que ses
compétences soient préservés dans la
durée avec des investissements
importants de la part de l'état un
deuxième pilier qui vise à accompagner
là aussi la transformation industrielle
de la sous traitance on sait qu'il ya
encore des et à franchir notamment pour
que l'ensemble de la filière soit
basculer dans l'industrie du futur et
conserve sa compétitivité
enfin le troisième pilier il est autour
de la structuration de la filière entre
donneurs d'ordre et sous traitants des
solidarités nécessaire que nous avons
déjà d'ailleurs mise en place au travers
de notre politique autour des des
paiements et de la résine istres la
parole est à monsieur damien pichereau
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la filière
automobile vit probablement la plus
grave crise de son histoire avec un
marché en chute de 90% au mois d'avril
et des difficultés d'approvisionnement
logistique ralentissant voire stoppant
les chaînes de production de nos usines
alors que 2020 s'annoncer comme une
année charnière pour cette industrie
grâce notamment aux contrats
stratégiques de filières porté par le
gouvernement les pertes financières sont
abyssales dans le monde entier cette
crise s'inscrit dans un contexte de
triple révolution industrielle pour le
secteur une révolution énergétique avec
l'électrification progressive des gammes
une révolution technologique avec
l'arrivée du véhicule autonome et enfin
une révolution des usages grâce au
développement de nouveaux services tels
que la location l'autopartage ou encore
le covoiturage bref plus que jamais
l'automobile doit se réinventer
c'est une question de survie pour une
industrie qui emploie 400 milles 2
citoyen sans compter la filière aval et
les sous traitants nous devons
collectivement être au rendez vous
devant nous c'est écrit une nouvelle
page de l'histoire automobile
l'histoire commencé au mans il ya près
de 150 ans avec la famille bollée la
france a été une grande nation
automobile du xxème siècle nos
constructeurs doivent être les leaders
européens de la mobilité du 21e siècle
telle est l'ambition que nous devons
porter une mobilité qui sera
inévitablement plus durable plus
accessible et plus connecté
nous avons d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de
débattre de ce point dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités fixant un
objectif de fin de vente des voitures à
énergies fossiles à horizon 2040 mesure
porté avec brio par notre collègue
jean-luc fuji et l'ensemble de notre
majorité
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
détailler les contours du plan de
relance automobile annoncée ce jour par
le président de la république
enfin quid du rétrofit cette innovation
dont notre majorité et le gouvernement
ont permis l'homologation permet en
effet la conversion de véhicules
thermiques en véhicules électriques et
s'inscrit pleinement dans notre
stratégie d'économie circulaire et dans
notre volonté ignalina ligne inaliénable
de réduire les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre du parc automobile français je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rinsch échec les
terres d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
pichereau nous n'avons jamais été aussi
proches de connaître les mesures du plan
de relance automobile mais je veux
pouvoir vous dire ici qu'il comporte
trois axes principaux le premier axe
vise à améliorer la qualité de l'offre
il s'agit pour répondre à la question de
comment faire en sorte que les français
puissent acheter des voitures fabriquées
en france de faire en sorte d'améliorer
le coût de revient de cette fabrication
pour ce faire c'est l'investissement
dans l'appareil de production dans
l'usiné du futur que nous allons
accompagner de manière massive
le deuxième axe il vise effectivement à
accompagner la demande et on le sait il
faut accompagner l'émergence de la
filière électrique peut être pas
seulement celle de l'hybride
rechargeable
à terme nous avons l'objectif aussi de
soutenir les véhicules hydrogène
ne sont pas aujourd'hui d'accès aussi
facile que les deux autres catégories et
donc nous allons agir dans cette
direction selon des termes que vous
allez pouvoir découvrir dans les
prochaines minutes
s'agissant du troisième axe il s'agit de
relocaliser les productions qui sont
compétitives en france cela veut dire
dans le cadre d'une charte entre les
donneurs d'ordre et les sous-traitants
de systématiquement considérer la france
comme un site possible de production et
de regarder les éléments qui nous manque
en termes de compétitivité pour les
combler pour les combler avec un soutien
je dirais des collectivités locales de
l'état ensemble et faire en sorte de
relocaliser notamment toutes les
activités autour de la traction
électrique moteur électrique batterie
électrique voilà à très grands traits
les termes de ce plan de soutien qui est
un plan de soutien massif dans les
montants massifs également dans sa
complétude puisqu'il répond à la fois
aux enjeux de la filière de production
mais également aux enjeux de laval les
900 mille emplois que vous signalez
merci madame la ministre
la parole à madame cécile untermaier
merci monsieur le président ce ça ne
sera plus la question d'automobiles mais
une question quand même très importante
c'est la question des masques monsieur
le premier ministre depuis le 11 mai ce
port des masques fait partie de notre
vie
il est obligatoire dans beaucoup de
situations et constitue un élément
déterminant des gestes barrières pour
tout un chacun
dès le 13 avril avec jean louis bricout
notre collègue nous avions demandé une
stratégie claire concernant la mise à
disposition des masques qui avons
renouvelé la demande d'une distribution
gratuite de deux masses que la balle à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
vous avez fait le choix de réglementer
les prix de masques jetables et adopter
une tva minoré l'encadrement des prix
fixe un plafond de 95 centimes d'euro le
masque jetable c'était sans doute
indispensable vu l'inflation constatée
sur ce produit
mais ce n'est pas une petite dépense
prenons l'exemple d'une aide ménagère
qui doit changer de masque lorsqu'elles
changent de domicile
elle sait qu'en février elle aurait pu
trouver une boîte de 50 masques pour moi
de 4 euros et que désormais elle doit
débourser près de 50 euros pour le même
nombre de masques elle perd près de 15 %
de son salaire net
horaire net hésitant à faire peser ce
coup sûr des employeurs mode
est retraité qui l'emploie le problème
reste donc entier
il est devant nous cette mesure
d'encadrement qui n'a pas totalement
rempli son office doit par ailleurs
prendre fin le 10 juillet prochain alors
monsieur le premier ministre quelle
mesure compte prendre le gouvernement
pour faire baisser le 1er prix des
masques et favoriser l'appropriation
d'une telle protection par tous sans que
cela représente un sacrifice pour les
plus modestes d'entre nous je vous
remercie
merci madame le député la parole à
madame agnès pannier reina chez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
untermaier merci de souligner les
efforts qui ont été faits par le
gouvernement en matière de prix du
masque effectivement ce plafonnement
tuner peut-être qu'ils vous avez raison
n'est pas satisfaisant parce que il
conduit avoir un prix élevé du masque
qui est le reflet de la réalité du
marché
je quand même vous rassurer d'essentiel
des masques chirurgicaux à usage unique
ce pur peuvent s'acheter sur le marché
plutôt du côté de 60 centimes ça reste
une dépense importante et c'est pour
cela que nous avons développé une
filière de masques lavables
réutilisables infiltration gras garantie
80% des masques qui sont aujourd'hui
produits en france sont une filtration
garanti supérieur à 90% ce sont donc des
masques de très grande qualité il n'y a
que deux pays en europe qui ont fixé ce
type de normes exigeantes
la france et le portugal est
probablement le portugal inspiré par la
france alors ces masques là nous avons
fait une enquête
cette enquête de la dgccrf ce que nous
avons mis en place un suivi des prix 30%
de ces masques sont accessibles à un
prix de l'ordre de 10 à 30 centimes
lusage cela nous paraît être un prix
beaucoup plus raisonnables et vous voyez
qu'on commence à converger vers le prix
du masques à usage unique
avant la crise qui est de l'ordre de 10
centimes
dans le détail c'est la politique que
nous menons et nous avons aujourd'hui
une filière industrielle qui est formé
avec plus de 500 entreprises qui ont été
qualifiés qui attendent d'ailleurs des
commandes parce qu'elles sont plutôt
surcapacitaire que
en situation de ne pas fournir le marché
et nous allons continuer à les
accompagner
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur stéphane baudu merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie des finances et
j'y associe mes collègues bruno fuchs et
philippe michel claes bauer madame la
ministre je souhaite vous interroger sur
l'évolution du droit des assurances dans
ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler désormais
le monde d'après face à la crise
sanitaire les entreprises paralysées ont
attendu de leur assurance un soutien
financier
beaucoup ne l'ont pas reçu ou plutôt pas
directement faute de clause qui
prévoyait une couverture des pertes
d'exploitation en cas de pandémie
l'état soutenu par cette assemblée a été
au rendez vous de la protection de deux
entreprises en particulier des plus
petites
et nous pouvons collectivement en être
fier mais dans cette situation inédite
le secteur de l'assurance malgré sa
participation au fonds de solidarité n'a
pas été à la hauteur des attentes et
cela interroge notre modèle de
protection et sa codification dans notre
droit
votre ministère s'est engagé à
travailler avec les assurances afin de
mieux adapter la couverture
assurancielle assurantielle aux aléas de
demain
c'est une absolue nécessité mais il nous
faut dans ce travail éviter de tomber
dans l'écueil d'une approche trop
sectorielle en effet je crois madame la
ministre que le monde d'avant révélé
déjà certaine fragilité
l'actuel régime de catastrophe naturelle
ne permet plus de faire face aux aléas
climatiques dont la fréquence s'accélère
comme les inondations ou la sécheresse
il s démunis de trop nombreuses familles
face aux sinistres qui touche leur
habitat ou leurs activités de même la
récurrence grandissant des conditions
météorologiques extrêmes frappe notre
agriculture fragilise son système
d'assurance et finalement menace notre
souveraineté alimentaire
c'est donc l'ensemble de notre approche
du risque et du cadre à assurantielle
que nous devons confronter aux menaces
d'aujourd'hui est ainsi repensé la
protection de nos concitoyens de nos
entreprises et de nos agriculteurs
dès lors ma question est la suivante
comment le gouvernement tente il
conduire ce travail de réforme
transversale
et inciter le secteur privé de
l'assurance à s'engager dans cette
nécessaire transformation merci chers
collègues la parole à madame agnès
pannier rue nager secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
audio merci pour votre question sur le
rôle des assurances dans cette crise
vous l'avez dit il on sait les
assurances ont contribué à hauteur de
400 millions d'euros au fonds de
solidarité c'est un premier élément
ils ont également suite à des
négociations qui ont été menées par le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
et bruno le maire se ils se sont engagés
à retourner 1,3 milliard d'euros
globalement de primes d'assurance et de
budget vers les assurés et à investir à
peu près la même somme dans les
entreprises françaises
donc c'est un engagement que nous
suivons est d'ailleurs que vous nous
avez demandé de suivre très précisément
au moment du projet de loi de finances
rectificatif que j'ai portée de devancer
devancé banc en notamment mais au delà
l'enjeu est effectivement la prise en
charge du risque assurantielle dans un
monde où les risques et le nombre de
risques ont tendu à augmenter et vous
avez tout à fait raison de dire qu'il
faut probablement pas si l'hôte et cette
approche puisqu'on la retrouve dans les
catastrophes naturelles pour les
particuliers dans le problématique de
l'agriculture dont classé à destination
de professionnels et également dans ce
risque sanitaire nouveau qui émergent
mais dont on peut penser qu'il pourrait
prendre une forme de récurrence si l'on
se positionne comme les pays asiatiques
eux ce n'est pas leur première
catastrophe sanitaire
ce n'est jamais que la troisième en
quelques années est donc cette nécessité
de comprendre ce risque et de l'assuré
est importante cela veut dire qu'il faut
avoir des systèmes avec des réassureurs
et un assureur ultime qui est l'état et
qui fait la péréquation de ces risques
donc effectivement nous avons entamé ses
discussions avec les assureurs nous les
avons entamé plus tôt par types de
risques mais je vous rejoins sur sur la
proche et nous allons ouvrir cette
constatation est tout député qui
seraient intéressés et évidemment le
bienvenu pour apporter sa pierre
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur eric coquerel
merci j'aurais aimé poser cette question
au ministre de l'économie des finances
que je vais le citer mais il n'est pas
là il est auprès du président est
manifestement premier ministre à la fois
emmanuel macron je dois dire que cette
manie de faire des annonces en plein
milieu d'une séance de questions au
gouvernement
et la marque d'un mépris de la
représentation nationale
de plus en plus évidente c'est pas grave
on va faire comme si le 9 mars
bruno le maire s'est déclaré prêt à
recourir à tous les moyens y compris la
nationalisation pour protéger les
entreprises françaises menacées par la
crise du cordat virus je n'ai pas cru
j'ai bien fait car hier on lui poser la
question suivante concernant l'activité
de renault en france
est ce que vous allez exigé de renault
de garder ouverts tous ses sites
industriels
il a répondu non on lui a alors demandé
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce
matin il n'y aura pas de suppression de
poste il a répondu non ce gouvernement
se renie sans complexe sans honte
vous avez parlé de contreparties aux
aides de l'état sur le plan automobile
mais vous avez déjà signé un chèque en
blanc de 20 milliards d'euros aux
entreprises sans condition vous annoncez
donner 5 milliards d'euros à renault
sans les forcer à produire en france
savez vous que le groupe n'a pas attendu
le coronavirus pour délocaliser le
qu'ovide 19 a bon dos ça fait des années
qu renault délocalise ses activités au
nom de sa stratégie financière
la part des véhicules produits en france
par renault n'a pas attendu l'épidémie
54 % en 2004 30 % en 2012
elle s'est effondrée à 10 7% en 2010 est
derrière ces chiffres c'est la mort
sociale de milliers de salariés
et pendant ce temps vous aviez donné
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
rien qu'en cice regarder le résultat
naïs que vous êtes et vous vous allez
continuer à donner l'argent des français
sans contrepartie à ces gens vous parlez
de créer des voitures plus écologiques
mais favoriser les délocalisations
abandonné l'idée de réalisation c'est
polluer moins
non évidemment avez vous changé votre
logiciel de paie lydie le pull et de vie
d'amy non je le demande puisque vous
abandonner nos usines à quoi servez-vous
merci monsieur de député la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rinsch et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
coquerel
vous avez raison
entre 2004 et 2010 est la part des
voitures fabriquées par renault en
france est passé de 51 % à 17 % soit une
division par trois entre 2004 et 2010
est de 2017 à 2020 je le rappelais 2019
ce gouvernement à augmenter l'emploi
industriel ça n'était pas arrivé entre
2000 et 2016
ça n'était pas arrivé entre 2000 et 2016
ce gouvernement a fait qu'il y a eu plus
de sites industriels ouverts en france
que de sites fermés ça n'était pas
arrivé depuis 15 ans ce gouvernement a
fait de la france une des premières
destinations pour les investissements
directs étrangers en europe et je crois
d'ailleurs que cette amélioration sera
encore sensible pour l'année 2019
là encore nous avons amélioré la
situation
donc si je vous reviens je rejoins sur
le diagnostic je crois qu'on ne vous a
pas attendu pour agir et c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce plan de soutien à
l'automobile que nous portons
aujourd'hui un plan de soutien qui met
la transition écologique et énergétique
au coeur du dispositif et qui de manière
concrète et pas dans le déni fait en
sorte qu'on développe le véhicule
électrique un plan de soutien qui fait
en sorte qu'on relocalise qu'on
relocalise les chaînes de traction
électriques et des véhicules en france
et qu'on ne fabrique pas à l'étranger
ça c'est contre ça c'est concret ça ce
sont des engagements un plan de soutien
qui fait en sorte que l'ensemble de la
filière soit solidaire et que les sous
traitants aujourd'hui qui ont longtemps
été tenue je dirais dans des situations
complexes notamment en période de crise
par les producteurs et sous traitants de
rang 1 soit aujourd'hui accompagné par
ces mêmes producteurs et c'est même son
de rang merci madame la ministre
la parade est un monsieur jean michel
clément et à lui seul
merci monsieur le président mais ma
secrétaire d'état à mon tour de vous
interroger
nous avons appris hier que par un
communiqué de presse que les règles de
prise en charge du chômage partiel à
l'échangé au 1er juin
l'état et l'unedic supporteront 60% de
la rémunération brute des salariés
contre 70% actuellement nous pensons que
l'activité partielle est au coeur de
notre système de soutien aux entreprises
dont l'activité est ralenti ou à l'arrêt
son évolution sp table mais doit être
adaptée finement mais un problème
demeure
la prise en charge des salariés quand la
reprise ne pourrait être totale d'où une
première question l'engagement de l'état
l'unedic est il amené à évoluer et selon
quel calendrier
madame la ministre la période qui
s'ouvre est aussi celle de tous les
dangers
nous allons devoir faire face à une
vague de liquidation d'entreprises et
des licenciements
or si le chômage partiel se transforme
en chômage tout court
le pari sera perdu la face du
confinement imposait une réponse
économique massive et rapide
la période actuelle requiert des
réponses tout aussi rapide mais adapter
par branches par secteur je dirais
presque par entreprise le président de
la république dévoile aujourd'hui un
plan de soutien au secteur automobile
ça a été longuement abordée mi-mai des
annonces ont concerné les acteurs du
tourisme
vous nous avez prévenu qu'un plan de
relance interviendrait mais pas avant
septembre
nous pensons que l'urgence nous impose
d'agir sans attendre en associant au
plus près les partenaires sociaux ainsi
une multitude de plans doit être lancée
par secteur ou en fonction des
caractéristiques
je pense par exemple aux entreprises
adaptées elle même dépendante de
donneurs d'ordres affecter gravement par
la crise sanitaire
nous pensons qu'il est urgent que la
reprise se mettre enfin ce tournant
écologique et sociale qui tardent tant
nous nous pouvons recommencer comme
avant
faisons de cette crise une opportunité
pour faire émerger de nouveaux modèles
de développement dans tous les secteurs
de notre économie car sont là les
emplois et la croissance de demain
êtes vous prêt à vous engager dans cette
voie madame la ministre
merci je règle à paarl l'état madame
agnès manière imagée secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député clément
je rejoins votre diagnostic c'est à dire
que la question que nous avons devant
nous c'est la façon d'accompagner le
capital humain et les salariés pour que
il traverse est cette crise en
préservant au maximum ce capital humain
c'est pour cette raison que muriel
pénicaud est en train de travailler sur
une
remise à une transition dans le
dispositif de chômage partiel qui
permettent justement de donner une
incitation aux entreprises pour mettre
en activité le maximum de salariés ce
qui est la direction préféré faciliter
le recours à la formation et je veux
signaler que depuis le début de la crise
le fn et emploi et le fn de formation a
été rechargées à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros et permet de financer pour des
personnes en situation de chômage
partiel des formations intégralement et
que ce dispositif gagnerait à être
utilisé de manière plus massive par les
entreprises et faire en sorte que les
restructurations si on en a soit
conduite de la manière la plus
responsable possible parce que nous ne
sommes pas dans le déni et si le chiffre
d'affaires d'une entreprise tombe à zéro
ce n'est pas le soutien de l'état qui va
faire changer la donne
c'est le fait de permettre aux personnes
qui sont dans cette entreprise de
pouvoir rebondir vers d'autres
entreprises
et c'est la philosophie dans lequel nous
nous inscrivons donc je veux vous
assurer muriel pénicaud à une approche
qui est effectivement très précises en
tenant en compte la situation de
certains secteurs qui sont encore
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt ou qui peine à
redémarrer
nous avons également en tête la
nécessité de préserver les compétences
technologiques
on a évoqué sur ses bancs l'aéronautique
et l'automobile
et nous serons donc au rendez-vous pour
accompagner au mieux les salariés
merci madame la ministre d'avoir ainsi
répandu à la 13è question et dernière
pour aujourd'hui qui vous étaient
adressées
la parole la parole est à monsieur régis
juanico
madame la ministre des sports comme nous
avons pu le constater lors de nos
auditions ces dernières semaines avec ma
collègue fabienne colboc la crise
sanitaire lié à la pandémie du
coronavirus constitue une menace grave
pour le sport amateur au delà de la fin
de saison les dirigeants bénévoles de
nos clubs sont inquiets pour la
pérennité de leur activité et de leur
partenariat à la rentrée prochaine
celles de septembre celle de tous les
dangers tous craignent de perdre des
licenciés pour des raisons financières
ou sanitaire d'autant que faute
d'équipements sportifs réouvert la
reprise des activités associatives
depuis le 11 mai est très limité y
compris dans le cadre périscolaire
selon une étude d'impact de la centrale
du sport une start-up stéphanoise en
lien avec sport et citoyenneté auprès de
3000 club
ces derniers ont dû annuler en moyenne
dix événements entre mars et juin pour
une perte financière estimée à dix mille
euros
les sponsors de ces clubs sont pour
moitié des artisans et commerçants des
bars et restaurants locaux durement
touché par la crise
l'enjeu est bien la survie pure et
simple de milliers d'associations
sportives sur le terrain qui en majorité
ne sont pas employeuse et donc n'ont pas
eu accès au fonds de solidarité
gouvernementale
la crise sanitaire a démontré la
nécessité d'un état fort dans le domaine
du sport les agents du ministère des
sports et les 1600 conseiller technique
et sportif ont fait preuve d'une
capacité d'adaptation qui fait honneur
aux services publics et leur statut doit
être enfin conforter mais au dollar à
madame la ministre
il y a urgence a lancé un plan de
sauvetage pour tous ces clubs en
difficulté voici quelques propositions
tout d'abord la création d'un fonds de
solidarité au niveau national avec
l'augmentation pérenne de 100 millions
d'euros du produit des trois taxes
affectées sur les jeux les paris
sportifs ou la taxe buffet ce fonds
spécifique permettrait des aides
directes ou de développer les emplois
sportifs qualifiés en particulier pour
les activités du sport santé bien-être
aux loisirs
deuxièmement des mesures de soutien au
sponsoring et mécénat sportive des clubs
locaux
enfin un chèque sport d'environ 100
euros à la rentrée pour les familles
remettrait de soutenir les dépenses
sportives comme la prise ou la reprise
de licence madame la ministre que
comptez vous faire
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame roxana maracineanu monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés cherchent et régis juanico
je suis d'accord avec vous la place de
nos associations sportives est centrale
dans nos vies pour nos enfants pour les
bénévoles qui font vivre cette passion
au quotidien comme pour toutes les
éducatrices et éducateurs qui travaille
et c'est bien cela qui justifie tout
l'accompagnement que nous leur avons
apporté pendant cette crise un soutien
moral et financier que votre rapport
fait avec fabienne colboc souligne et je
vous en remercie
malgré cela nos associations souffrent
de ce moment de crise sanitaire parce
qu'elle se pose la même question que
nous tous
quand pourra-t-on revenir à une vie
normale et si on est amené à faire du
sport autrement comment leur activité
va-t-elle pouvoir évoluer
combien d'adhérents pour vous
pourront-elles accueillir avec elle
manque à gagner quelles perspectives
nouvelles de développer leurs actions et
leurs activités comment leur offre va
pouvoir s'adapter se transformer il n'y
a pas un jour où je ne me demande pas
comment les aider à fonctionner au mieux
à solliciter mes collègues de la santé
de l'éducation de la ville pour leur
ouvrir de nouveaux territoires
d'intervention et c'est encore plus
nécessaire avec la survenue de la crise
mais vous avez raison aujourd'hui elles
ont besoin de notre aide et de notre
solidarité de notre confiance et de
notre soutien
c'est ce que nous faisons je me bats
chaque jour pour que le sport ne soit
pas oublié et il ne l'est pas il ne
l'est pas dans le cadre des mesures de
droit commun de soutien économique il ne
l'est pas du point de vue budgétaire et
dans la gestion de cette crise la
création de l' agence nationale du sport
voté par cette assemblée et dans
laquelle vous siégez monsieur le député
nous a été très utile pour agir ensemble
de manière coordonnée adapté aux
réalités des territoires avec tous les
acteurs de la nouvelle gouvernance du
sport
l'état travaille à l'élaboration d'un
plan de soutien à l'activité associative
pour qu elles enrichissent leurs offres
pour aussi soutenir en fasse la demande
du sport et toutes les propositions vous
avez fait seront les bienvenus cette
crise est l'occasion de nous re penser
inventé le possible c'est rapprocher
l'école et le sport nous lente hamon
inventé le possible c'est aussi repenser
ensemble l'offre des associations pour
l'accueil des enfants et des familles
sur d'autres temps que nous connaissons
l'accueil des adultes pour de la
prévention santé de la réparation social
inventé le possible ensemble ces données
une autre place au sport dans notre
société merci madame la ministre
la parole de monsieur pierre alex
anglade
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur la pandémie de
coronavirus engendre des défis de taille
et il est essentiel de les relever de
manière coordonnée avec nos partenaires
européens
c'est le chemin tracé par le président
de la république au début de la crise et
qui aura permis de prendre des décisions
importantes pour l'avenir de l'union
européenne et de ses citoyens je pense
évidemment à l'accord franco allemand
mais il faut aussi reconnaître qu'avec
le virus les réflexes mathieu nationaux
étaient parfois plus prompt que la
volonté de trouver des solutions
communes et en particulier sur les
frontières
dans un élan désordonnée et non
concertée un nombre sans précédent
d'états européens ont réintroduit des
contrôles aux frontières intérieures de
l'espace schengen ou ont procédé à la
fermeture partielle ou totale de ses
frontières
si ces mesures ont été acceptés ou
plusieurs de la crise elles pèsent
désormais lourdement sur les vies de
millions de citoyens français et
européens qui ont construit leur vie
professionnelle étudiante ou familiale
dans une zone transfrontalière ou dans
un autre état de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui encore alors que le
déconfinement et en avait partout en
europe la rouverture en ordre dispersé
des frontières envoie le mauvais signal
aux européens ce manque de coordination
abîme la confiance entre les états et il
est désormais nécessaire de mener
l'action rapide et coordonnée pour
éviter la fragmentation de l'espace
schengen partout en europe les appels en
faveur du rétablissement la liberté de
circulation au sein de cet espace se
multiplient je me joins à ces appels et
à celui des présidents ferrand et chats
aux bleus prononcé aujourd'hui l'europe
ne peut pas être un grand espace de
liberté par temps calme et se
transformer en un agrégat se méfiant un
agrégat d'état se méfiant les uns des
autres
lorsqu'une crise se présente sous peine
de perdre de son sens et le soutien de
nos concitoyens monsieur le ministre le
croit dans la souveraineté dans les
souverainetés nationales qui sont celles
de nos états mais je crois aussi dans la
souveraineté européenne car les défis à
venir ne sont plus seulement à l'échelle
de nos nations
cette crise le démontre à nouveau et
lorsque l'on parle des frontières les
mesures que nous avons à prendre nous
devons les prendre à l'échelle de
l'europe car c'est dans cet espace que
nous avons construit nos libertés et que
nous aurons
instruire dans les mois et les années à
venir les moyens de nous protéger aussi
monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous dire quelles sont les
mesures que la france et ses partenaires
européens entendent prendre pour
rétablir la liberté de circulation et à
quelle échéance
le droit fondamental des citoyens
européens à se déplacer sera garanti que
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole et à monsieur christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur c'est
le président mesdames messieurs les
députés monsieur le député pierre
alexandre anglade le 18 mars
la france a fait le choix avec joie de
fermer ses frontières comme de très
nombreux pays européens pour limiter la
propagation du virus pour protéger nos
concitoyens et pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions organiser au mieux le
combat qui a été mené partout en france
contre le coc vide 19 mai vous avez
raison
à ce moment là elle décisions ont été
prises dans l'essentiel des cas de façon
unilatérale non coordonnée depuis chaque
semaine nous avons un conseil des
ministres de l'intérieur au niveau
européen pour tenter d'harmoniser les
conditions de sortie et vous avez raison
encore nous n'avons pas réussi à le
faire de façon optimale et coordonnée au
niveau européen mais ce que je veux vous
dire et vous le savez c'est que de façon
bilatérale avec chacun de mes collègues
ministres de l'intérieur des pays
frontaliers nous avons fait en sorte que
notamment pour les près de 360 milles
français qui travaillent dans le pays
voisin nous puissions garantir le bon
déroulement du transport vers leur
travail
nous avons assoupli au fur et à mesure
des semaines les conditions pour que
soit prise en compte des situations
individuelles de parents par exemple
qu'ils étaient confrontés à l'incapacité
à cause de la frontière de voir leurs
enfants
nous avons aussi ces derniers jours sous
l'autorité d'une instruction du premier
ministre fait en sorte que les
travailleurs saisonniers puissent venir
rejoindre les champs dans notre pays en
particulier de même les travailleurs et
économique et près de 65% des
sollicitations ont pu aboutir
mais maintenant il est nécessaire que
nous puissions coordonnait tous ensemble
les conditions de
pour retrouver les conditions normales
de circulation dans nos pays et jeudi le
premier ministre et le président de la
république sur la base des informations
sanitaires dont nous disposerons serons
amenés à prendre décision pour que nous
puissions en infra schengen retrouver au
plus vite les conditions normales de
libre circulation au sein de l'espace
européen
bien évidemment cela sera déclaré vous
savez au de la jungle je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur christophe di pompéo merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur gabriel a tall
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre
depuis trois ans le gouvernement et la
majorité poursuivre un cap celui de
l'émancipation notre jeunesse
parce que tout le monde n'est pas avec
les mêmes chances et que la république
doit accompagner chacune et chacun parce
que les accidents de parcours les
difficultés imprévues peuvent réduire le
champ des possibles développements de la
garantie visage pour que les jeunes
puissent se loger avec l'état comme
garant développement massif de la
garantie jeunes de l'apprentissage de la
formation avec l'investissement des 15
milliards d'euros dans les compétences
développement du service national
universel et du service civique pour que
chaque jeune puisse mesurer tout ce
qu'il peut apporter à son pays
ces réformes sont cohérentes et il y a
quelques mois encore se sont traduites
par des résultats concrets
en témoigne par exemple la hausse
spectaculaire de l'apprentissage et de
l'accès des boursiers à l'enseignement
supérieur la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons aujourd'hui est un défi que
vous avez rappelé que vous avez rappelé
qu'une crise économique frappe toujours
en premier lieu les jeunes alors qu'on
évalue à 700 mille le nombre de jeunes
qui pourraient être dans la recherche
d'un emploi 10 septembre cette situation
provoque une inquiétude considérable au
delà de l'aide exceptionnelle de 200
euros pour plus de 800 mille jeunes
précaires de moins de 25 ans qui a été
récemment annoncée comment pouvez-vous
rassurer notre jeunesse l'a rassuré sur
son avenir professionnel face à la crise
l'a rassuré sur sa capacité à se former
la rassurer sur la place qu'elle pourra
occuper dans la construction de la
société l'après crise je remercie
merci chers collègues la parole
tom chez gabriela tall secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
christophe di pompéo formatrice vous
m'adressez une question qui porte sur
l'impact de la crise du coronavirus sur
notre jeunesse et je veux en profiter
pour adresser un message
quant à l'image qu'à renvoyer notre
jeunesse pendant le début de cette crise
on a entendu beaucoup de personnes dire
estimé que des hordes de jeunes se
rendrait dans la rue pour rompre le
confinement ne respecteraient pas les
règles sanitaires qui ont été édités
et pourtant nous avons vu des jeunes qui
ont fait preuve d'une incroyable
résilience qui ont tenu dans cette
période alors que c'est difficile et
nous avons vu des jeunes qui ont mis à
profit ce temps pour être utile pour
s'engager pour leur pays et je veux
saluer les cinquante huit mille jeunes
du service civique qui se sont rendu
utile auprès des associations des corps
en uniforme des services publics
je veux saluer les jeunes engagés dans
la réserve civique 40% des trois cent
mille français engagés dans la réserve
civiques avaient moins de 30 ans et une
très belle image qui a été envoyé il
faut le dire et le souligner est
évidemment que cette crise fait naître
des inquiétudes pour l'avenir de notre
jeunesse et notamment des inquiétudes en
matière d'emploi c'est là notre grande
priorité depuis le début de ce
quinquennat permettre à tous les jeunes
de conquérir leur autonomie par la
formation par les compétences et par
l'emploi
d'où la mobilisation de muriel pénicaud
qui a permis d'atteindre un niveau
historique en matière d'apprentissage
l'an dernier d'où les 15 milliards
d'euros mis sur la table via le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
pour former un million de jeunes il faut
poursuivre évidemment dans cette
direction c'est la raison pour laquelle
je travaille avec bruno le maire muriel
pénicaud à un plan qui sera présenté
avant l'été pour soutenir l'emploi des
jeunes trois priorités la lutte contre
le décrochage notamment dans la voie
professionnelle scolaire le maintien de
la dynamique en matière de formation et
en matière d'apprentissage et puis enfin
l'accès à l'embauché sept cent mille
jeunes doivent arriver sur le marché du
travail dans les prochains mois aucun
jeune ne doit être laissé sans solution
et c'est à cela que nous travaillons
aujourd'hui et je sais que nous y
travaillerons ensemble je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre nous
terminons cette séance avec deux
questions diverses
la parole est au président matthieu
orphelin de la parole merci monsieur le
président présidente écologie démocratie
solidarité
trois mots monsieur le premier ministre
trois impératifs majeurs trois priorités
indissociables que notre nouveau groupe
fera résonner avec vigueur à l'assemblée
nationale et le dans le débat public la
crise ducobu 19 nous oblige à dépasser
les postures et les clivages à
construire collectivement le monde
d'après les citoyens le demandent nous y
sommes prêts nous soutiendrons chacune
des avancées qu'elles viennent du
gouvernement ou de n'importe lequel des
bancs démocrate de cette assemblée
mais nous serons toujours exigeants non
pas pour imposer un dogme mais parce que
les urgences écologiques et sociales
nous y oblige
nous sommes un groupe indépendant avec
une seule volonté être utile à notre
pays
monsieur le premier ministre soyez avec
nous travaillons ensemble nous sommes un
groupe de propositions nous portons 15
premières solutions concrètes et
ambitieuses
êtes vous prêt à tirer avec nous les
leçons de la crise pour que la
transition écologique le renouveau
démocratique et le progrès social
franchissent un nouveau cap
êtes vous prêt à mieux construire avec
le parlement avec les acteurs de la
société civile avec les citoyens dans un
grenelle du monde d'après etes-vous
prêts dans le ségur de la santé à
soutenir les propositions de
revalorisation salariale dès 2021 pour
les aides soignantes pour les aides à
domicile pour les infirmières êtes vous
prêts à soutenir nos propositions de
relocalisation et de création d'emplois
sur les territoires et en europe et à
conditionner les soutiens de l'état
devrait contrepartie
êtes vous prêts à soutenir plus
fortement les collectivités locales en
consacrant 5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an pour les
accompagner dans leurs investissements
dans la transition mer et sont logiques
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le président je réponds bien
volontiers à votre à votre question et
je voudrais vous dire les choses le plus
simplement possible
vous me demandez si j'approuve tout une
série de propositions sur lesquelles
vous avez sans doute travailler et que
vous livrer au débat public
moi je vais vous répondre clairement
j'ai été nommé pour mettre en oeuvre les
engagements du président de la
république tous ses engagements
tous les engagements qu'il a pris
j'essaie de les mettre en oeuvre
mais je reconnais monsieur le président
que c'est pas toujours facile parce que
nous vivons dans un monde compliqué
parce que des choses que nous espérions
faire plus vite se heurte parfois à des
freins se heurte parfois des obstacles
parce qu'elles doivent être travaillés
adaptés en fonction des circonstances en
fonction de l'expression de nos
concitoyens tout cet ensemble de mesures
que nous avons prises
tout cet ensemble de mesures que nous
allons continuer à prendre pour
respecter à la fois la philosophie qui a
été proposé par prise en mains publiques
aux français au moment de l'élection
présidentielle et les engagements que
les membres de la majorité ont pris au
moment des élections législatives
tout cela je mens estime comptable et
j'essaie de les mettre en oeuvre et je
le fais le plus complètement possible au
rythme qui me paraît le le plus adapté
en tenant compte des réalités en tenant
compte parfois des difficultés et je le
fais avec le soutien de la majorité et
même parfois monsieur le président avec
le soutien d' un peu au delà de la
majorité et quand c'est le cas je m'en
réjouis et encore plus
merci monsieur le préfet
la parole est un monsieur jean paul
lecoq
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
l'accord signé par les deux dirigeants
israélien benny gantz et benyamin
nétanyahou pour conduire les affaires de
leur pays ne peut pas nous laisser
indifférents leurs programmes ne
mentionne que deux choses la gestion de
la crise sanitaire actuelle et
l'invasion de la cisjordanie
violant délibérément le droit
international le droit du peuple
palestinien à vivre sur ses propres
terres vous avez déjà monsieur le
ministre condamné avec des mots cet
accord il est temps de le faire avec des
actes le premier acte symbolique mais ô
combien important serait de reconnaître
immédiatement l'état palestinien
vous pourriez aussi et sans délai
interdire les produits des colonies
israéliennes sur le territoire français
tout en travaillant à faire de même à
l'échelle de l'union européenne
cela permettrait par la même occasion à
la france de se remettre
enfin en conformité avec les conventions
de genève l'accord d'association entre
israël et l'union européenne pourraient
aussi être suspendu temporairement en
parallèle la suspension temporaire des
accords de coopération bilatéraux franco
israélien serait une mesure de rétorsion
adaptée et rapide vous pourriez
également mettre fin temporairement à la
coopération militaire et sécuritaire
avec l'état d'israël
il faut faire comprendre par tous les
moyens qu'il n'est plus possible de
coopérer avec un état qui met en cache
gaza qui votent des lois d'apartheid et
qui tire à barel à balles réelles sur de
jeunes manifestants enfin la france
pourrait soutenir plus fermement et
publiquement la cour pénale
internationale dans son intention
d'ouvrir une enquête sur les crimes de
guerre commis en palestine par israël
monsieur le ministre arrêtons d'être
fort avec les faibles et faible avec les
forts c'est l'impunité d'israël qui
pousse son gouvernement aller toujours
plus loin dans laviolette dans la
violation des droits humains et du droit
international
agissez tout de suite vous en avez la
responsabilité historique
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le monsieur le député lecoq
vous avez rappelé que désormais il y à
un gouvernement en israël
ce n'était pas arrivé depuis décembre
2018 et nous voulons avoir avec ce
gouvernement
une relation d'amitié de coopération qui
président aux relations entre la france
et israël depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs l'occasion de m'entretenir
avec le ministre affaires étrangères
monsieur ashkenazi dès dimanche qui
vient vous avez rappelé à mai mais nous
serons très attentifs aux décisions qui
seront prises au sujet des territoires
palestiniens vous avez rappelé et vous
avez raison que le gouvernement qui
vient d'être formé l'a été sur la base
d'un accord de coalition qui permet
l'annexion d'une partie de la
cisjordanie à brève échéance
et lors de son investiture le premier
ministre monsieur netanyahou a
d'ailleurs réaffirmé sa détermination à
s'engager rapidement dans cette voie une
telle décision
mesdames et messieurs les députés serait
une violation grave du droit
international
elle contribuerait à attiser les
tensions et compromettrait gravement la
solution des deux états qui est la seule
à long terme qui permet de garantir la
paix et la stabilité dans la région
elle irait donc à l'encontre des
intérêts d israël a comme des
palestiniens est la priorité pour la
france là maintenant c'est en lien avec
ses partenaires européens et arabes
d'éviter qu'une telle situation se
produise une nous mobilisons pour cela
les états membres de l'union européenne
et nous appelons le gouvernement
israélien s'abstenir de toute mesure
unilatérale en particulier l'annexion et
monsieur le député compte tenu de la
gravité d'une telle décision
je vous le dis ici une telle décision ne
pourrait rester sans réponse
merci monsieur le ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue